Testing. Testing, testing, testing. Testing. Testing. Is it hot? Is it hot? Is it hot? Testing 1-2.
测试。测试，测试，测试。测试。测试。热吗？热吗？热吗？测试1-2。
Testing 1-2. Testing 1-2. Testing 1-2. Oh, look at Euras. Oh. Okay, wait. So wait. I got a really quick game. It's called Quick, Quick, Quick.
测试1-2。测试1-2。测试1-2。哦，看看尤拉斯。哦。好吧，等等。所以等等。我有一个超级简单的游戏。它叫“快、快、快”。
Okay. And I'm going to say, Quick, Quick, Quick, and I'm going to say, name three something, right? Okay. So for you, if so, quick, quick, quick, name three brands of soap. Dov, ivory, and I'm just quick. Okay, so quick, quick, name three problems, dental problems, go, name three dental problems. Oh, you've got to have access, you've got a cavity, and you've got a punch in the mouth. Okay, what about you, quick, quick, quick, three great sports teams.
好的。然后我会说，“快、快、快”，接着我会说，说出三样东西的名字，对吧？好的。所以对你来说，如果，那么，快，快，快，说出三个肥皂品牌。多芬，象牙，然后我很快。好吧，那快，快，说出三个问题，牙科问题，快，说出三个牙科问题。哦，你得有蛀牙，你有蛀牙，然后你在嘴上挨了一拳。好吧，那你呢，快，快，快，三个伟大的运动队。
Okay, what about you? Quick quick quick three great sports teams Quick the birds the dinosaur isn't that okay, oh Listen, let's just forget this let's just get down to what we came here to do the last show up Oh Yes Oh, man. It's over here. Yes. Look at this. So nice. You guys are last. You guys are last. You guys are last.
好吧，那你呢？快，快，快，三个伟大的运动队，快，小鸟队，恐龙队，不是这样的吗，好吧，哦，听着，我们别管这个了，让我们直奔我们来这里要做的事情吧，最后一场演出，哦，是的，哦，天哪，它在这儿，是的，看这个，太棒了，你们是最后一场，你们是最后一场，你们是最后一场。
This guy owns a place. You already seen it? Yeah. This guy owns a place. He's looking to bust some heads. Yeah. It's our last show of the show. It's our last show of the show.
这家伙是这儿的老板。你已经看过了？对。这家伙是这儿的老板。他准备大干一场了。是的。这是我们节目的最后一场秀。这是我们节目的最后一场秀。
Oh, wow. And we're going to, this is it. We're so excited that you guys wasted your money to come here tonight. We got a money. Yeah. Right? We're going to try to put full dollar value in it. We've got a pretty good guest, not great.
哦，哇。我们要，就是这样。我们非常高兴你们这群人今晚花冤枉钱来这里。我们有钱。是啊。对吧？我们要尽量让它物超所值。我们有一个相当不错的嘉宾，虽然不是顶级。
Not great. Pretty good. But we've been on the roads the last couple of weeks, and we went all over the country, we started in DC, and then we went to Boston, and we went to New York, in Chicago, and Madison, Wisconsin. Oh! We had an incredible special appearance.
不是顶级。相当不错。但我们在过去的几周里一直在路上，我们跑遍了全国，我们从华盛顿开始，然后去了波士顿，然后去了纽约、芝加哥和威斯康星州麦迪逊市。哦！我们有一个令人难以置信的特别嘉宾。
By my sister Tracy! Tracy! And I think that Tracy got a warmer reception than we did. Yeah, for sure. Anyway, thank you for coming here and listening. We're going to sit in the sun to show. You get there because you're guest. You're there?
由我的妹妹特雷西！特雷西！而且我觉得特雷西受到的热烈欢迎比我们还要多。是的，肯定的。不管怎样，谢谢你们来到这里听我们唠叨。我们要坐在阳光下演出。你到那儿是因为你是嘉宾。你在那儿吗？
I don't care. Oh, boy. Oh. You haven't sat in the center since... Since Conan. Oh, wow. So all the way back to Boston. Yeah, thank you. This is a great interview, by the way.
我不在乎。哦，天哪。哦。你从……从柯南开始就没坐在正中间过。哦，哇。所以一直追溯到波士顿。是的，谢谢。顺便说一句，这是一次很棒的采访。
Yeah. No. How did you get started in show business? That's a great question. I wasn't expecting it out of you. Um... LAUGHTER Um, sorry, just before I... green.
是的。不。你是怎么进入演艺圈的？这是一个很好的问题。我没想到你会这么问。嗯……笑声，嗯，抱歉，就在我……绿色之前。
Um... LAUGHTER Oh, what's your favorite color? No, they know. They know. All right, so I, I, you know, people are so nice to come back stage and they say nice things, all through this whole tour. Sometimes, I do think I have a little bit of face blindness, of undiagnosed face blindness, because sometimes I really truly don't recognize people
嗯……笑声，哦，你最喜欢的颜色是什么？不，他们知道。他们知道。好吧，所以，我，我，你知道，大家在后台都太好了，他们会说好话，在整个巡演过程中都是这样。有时，我真的觉得我有点面盲症，有些未确诊的面盲症，因为有时我真的完全认不出人来，
and I'm making an asset of myself. And so a quick story, I was remodeling my house and I came outside, thank you, thank you. Oh, it doesn't get any gager than remodeling your house. And so the, and I walk outside and this woman's walking down the sidewalk and she says, she goes, I love what you did with the house. I would love to see the inside of it sometime.
然后我还自作聪明。所以讲个简短的故事，我当时在装修房子，我走到外面，谢谢，谢谢。哦，没有什么比装修房子更让人觉得无聊的了。然后，我走到外面，一个女人正沿着人行道走过来，她说，她去，我喜欢你对房子做的一切。我真想什么时候看看里面的样子。
And I'm like, who are you? I was like, okay, like what am I supposed to do? And the conversation came and went on and I was feeling very awkward and I go, I'm sorry, do we know each other? She goes, it's Julio, your next turn, neighbor of 20 years. And then the worst comeback you could ever come up with, I go, did you change your hair? You look so good.
我就想，你是谁？我当时就想，好吧，我该怎么办？然后对话断断续续地进行着，我觉得非常尴尬，我说，不好意思，我们认识吗？她说，我是胡里奥，你做了20年的邻居。然后我说了史上最糟糕的应答，我说，你换发型了吗？你看起来太棒了。
That's gayer. That's gayer. That's definitely gayer. Oh, and another one. This is why I think I have it, because another one during Will and Grace, remember Tracy Lorde's the porn star? Sure. No.
那更同性恋了。那更同性恋了。那绝对更同性恋了。哦，还有另一个。这就是为什么我觉得我有这个病，因为在《威尔和格蕾丝》期间还有另一个，还记得色情明星特雷西·洛德吗？当然。不。
No. Oh. No. No. No. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh.
不。哦。不。不。不。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。
Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh.
哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。
Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. she talked quite a bit.
哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。她挺能聊的。
Yeah, actually. So she, I didn't know. So she came on as a guest, darn, willing, grace. And I'm such an idiot. She sat down. I literally said, oh my god, I loved you in the hand that rocks the cradle. I thought she was Rebecca de Mournet.
是的，实际上。所以她，我不知道。所以她作为嘉宾上了节目，该死，威尔和格蕾丝。我真是个白痴。她坐了下来。我简直说了，哦，天哪，我太喜欢你在《推翻摇篮的手》里的表现了。我以为她是丽贝卡·德·莫尔内。
And she looked at me like, excuse me. And all I didn't even say anything, I'm like, I'm going to be right back. I get to get some water. And I just, because somebody me like, excuse me. And all I didn't even say anything, I'm like, I'm gonna be right back in a get some water. And I just, because somebody's like, that's not Rebecca de Mourne. What else? Are you happy to be done with the tour, both of you? Well, I'm happy and sad.
然后她看着我，仿佛在说，不好意思。然后我甚至什么都没说，我就说，我马上回来。我去弄点水。然后我只是，因为有人看着我，仿佛在说，不好意思。然后我甚至什么都没说，我就说，我马上回来拿点水。然后我只是，因为有人说，那不是丽贝卡·德·莫尔内。还有什么？你们俩对巡演结束感到高兴吗？嗯，我既高兴又难过。
Huh? I'm happy and sad. What I said. What's the happy part? The happy part is that of the happy part is the... You get to answer a second. Or really, 30 seconds. No, no, no. Because he's going, Sean is about to go is that the happy part is the... You get to... We're really sure it's gonna be a happy part. Because he's going...
啊？我既高兴又难过。我刚才说的。高兴的部分是什么？高兴的部分是……你得等一秒钟回答。或者确切地说，30秒。不，不，不。因为他要说，肖恩正准备去……高兴的部分是……你得……我们真的很确定会有一个高兴的部分。因为他要……
No. He's... Ashaan is about to go on the road for seven months to go do a play like tomorrow. And he's been doing all of this for his final week before... Yeah, cool. Thank you. Thank you.
不。他……肖恩明天就要出发去外地巡演七个月演一出戏了。他一直在忙所有这些，就在他最后一周之前……是的，酷。谢谢。谢谢。
That's very nice of you. Anybody here see Promises Promises? No, that's very nice of you to say. It's called Good Night Oscar. It opens at the Goodman Theater in Chicago and then Broadway after that. So, but that's nice. I say, no, I'm happy because I feel like it was a success.
你太好了。这里有人看《承诺，承诺》吗？不，你这么说真是太好了。它叫《晚安，奥斯卡》。它将在芝加哥古德曼剧院首演，然后去百老汇。所以，不过这很好。我说，不，我很高兴，因为我觉得这是一次成功。
I had a great time with you guys. I feel very happy that we did it, but sad because it'll be gone. Yeah. It could have really been a shit show, right? Yeah. We didn't know what we still don't know what the hell we're doing. And to think that people would be engaged
我和你们度过了一段美好的时光。我为我们完成了它感到非常高兴，但又难过，因为它要结束了。是啊。本来真的可能是一场灾难，对吧？是啊。我们不知道，我们到现在还不知道我们到底在干什么。一想到人们会花半小时或整整一个小时来听我们聊天，并为此着迷、娱乐，
and entertained for half hour or full hour with us talking is stunning. And we might be blowing it right now. Right? We were doing so good up to here. I know. It went really well. Did you black out?
这太让人震惊了。我们现在可能正把它搞砸。对吧？我们之前表现得那么好。我知道。进行得非常顺利。你刚才失忆了吗？
Did you black out for a second? I'm still out. But I think we may have pulled it off without a real stinker. I have one more embarrassing face line of story. Can I just share? Yeah, of course. So I went to the premiere screening of Transparent. Remember that TV show?
你刚才有一瞬间断片了吗？我还没缓过神来。但我认为我们可能没有闹出什么真正的大笑话，就成功撑过来了。我还有一个更尴尬的面盲症故事。我能分享一下吗？可以，当然。所以我去了《透明家庭》的首映放映会。还记得那个电视剧吗？
Sure. And it was before it was it was before it was on TV, it was especially event you could watch the first two episodes. It's like, oh my god, I walk up to, what's his name? Take a time. J. Duplass. J. Duplass is an amazing actor, right? Sure.
当然。那是在它播出之前，那是在它上电视之前，这是一个特别活动，你可以观看前两集。就像，哦，天哪，我走向，他叫什么名字？等一下。杰·杜普拉斯。杰·杜普拉斯是个很棒的演员，对吧？当然。
And I walk up to him, I'm like, oh my god, you were so great. You were so amazing. And he's like, oh, and I'm like, no, no, no, that was such an incredible show. I can't believe nobody's ever tackled a subject. I just went on and on and on. And I was like, you're so great.
然后我走向他，我说，哦，天哪，你太棒了。你太不可思议了。然后他说，哦，然后我说，不，不，不，那真是一部不可思议的节目。我简直不敢相信从来没有人涉猎过这个主题。我就滔滔不绝地一直说。然后我就说，你太棒了。
And Scott even has been grabbed my arm. And I was like, oh, OK, well, I'll see you later. He's like, OK, he goes, that's Molly Shannon's husband, Fritz. LAUGHTER And I was like, oh, and I know Fritz very well. So, yeah. And then I, and then I was like, do I say something
斯科特甚至还拉了我的胳膊。然后我说，哦，好吧，那我回头见。他说，哦，他说，那是莫莉·香农的丈夫，弗里茨。笑声，然后我说，哦，而且我非常了解弗里茨。所以，是的。然后我，然后我就在想，我是该对
to Molly and Fritz or do I not? Oh my God, it's gonna be so embarrassed because every time I see her, then it's gonna be in the back of her. You know what, I'm gonna email her. I was like, oh my God, Molly, I can't believe I thought Fritz was J.D. Plus and she emailed me back. She was like, we cannot stop laughing on the car right home.
莫莉和弗里茨说点什么，还是不说？天哪，这会太尴尬了，因为每次我见到她，这件事都会浮现在她的脑海里。你知道吗，我要给她发邮件。我当时就想，哦，天哪，莫莉，我真不敢相信我把弗里茨当成了杰·杜普拉斯，然后她给我回信说，我们在回家的车里笑得停不下来。
It was pretty bad. We're getting old. We're getting old. And the brain starts to go. You guys are. I don't have any, yeah. You still play, you still, you play. I still play like 35 to 30.
这挺糟糕的。我们老了。我们老了。大脑开始衰退了。你们是。我没有任何，是的。你还在玩，你还在，你还在玩。我还在玩35到30左右的。
Right, you really do. I don't make the rules, dude. You have no socks on it. Do you have those weird sort of hide the socks that just hide in the bottom of the shoe? No, no seams. Yeah. Right. No.
对，你真的在玩。我可不制定规则，老兄。你连袜子都没穿。你穿的那种藏在鞋子底部的奇怪的隐形袜吗？不，没有缝线。对。对吧。不。
Prove it to me right now. Okay. Oh, oh, oh, oh. Oh. Oh. So, because those are not a good look, those little things. Isn't that what when a woman goes to try on shoes at a shoe store, high heels, they've got those little things in there. Well, men, too, dude.
现在就证明给我看。好的。哦，哦，哦，哦。哦。哦。因为那些鞋不好看，那些小东西。女人去鞋店试高跟鞋时，里面不是都有那种小东西吗？嗯，男人也有，老兄。
Well, it looks like a, it looks like a high heel. It looks like a high heel. But they have those little like like, temporary socks for everybody. And it's not a good look for men. You either got to go without socks or put them on. Who likes the no socks look? Anybody? Thank you.
嗯，它看起来像个，它看起来像个高跟鞋。它看起来像个高跟鞋。但每个人都有那种小小的，像临时袜子一样的东西。这对男人来说可不好看。要么光脚，要么穿上。谁喜欢不穿袜子的造型？有人吗？谢谢。
That was, like, 20 people. Good for you. I can't pull that off. Good for you. It's a... yeah, it's a very unique look. It looks like a palm... Feels like sneaker. Um. I don't know the reference. It was a commercial where women are playing basketball
大概有20个人吧。真为你高兴。我可驾驭不了。真为你高兴。这是一个……是的，这是一个非常独特的造型。看起来像个棕榈……感觉像运动鞋。嗯。我不懂这个梗。这是一个广告，里面女人穿着高跟鞋打篮球。
and they're high heels. Yeah. Well, what was that fun? It was some shoe company. I don't know. We have a lot of fun. We have a lot of fun together. We have a lot of fun with you guys,
是的。好吧，那好玩吗？那是某个鞋业公司。我不知道。我们玩得很开心。我们在一起玩得很开心。我们和你们一起玩得很开心，
knowing that you guys are having fun with us. That's a true story. Thanks for listening to our garbage. Truly. Truly, we really mean it when we say we can't believe it. We're truly humbled. And that you want to get involved with us and laugh, and all the stupid shit we talk about.
知道你们和我们玩得很开心。这是一个真实的故事。谢谢你们听我们的废话。真的。真的，当我们说我们不敢相信时，我们是认真的。我们真的很谦卑。而且你们还愿意和我们一起胡闹、欢笑，谈论我们说的那些蠢话。
Because that's what we do all the time. And we're really happy to be back here with you guys, with our family and friends, a lot of whom are here at tonight. And so we wanted, yeah, and we wanted to do a show back here in our hometown. We wanted to do a show that really was representative of how great we feel, and how grateful we are for you guys and for our hometown. We wanted to do a show that really was representative of how great we feel,
因为我们一直都在这么做。我们真的很高兴能和你们，和我们的家人朋友们一起回到这里，今晚有很多家人朋友都在现场。所以我们想，是的，我们想在我们的家乡办一场演出。我们想办一场真正能代表我们感觉有多棒的演出，以及我们对你们和我们的家乡有多么感激。我们想办一场真正能代表我们感觉有多棒的演出，
and how grateful we are for you guys and for our friends. So with that in mind, our guest tonight is someone that we all hold dear to our hearts and we love very much. He's just the funniest. He's such a good friend of ours. We just love him to death. And these got, for the first time, we all know who the guest is because we're at the end of the tour and we've invited our really good friend, our pal, the hilarious, the kind, the generous, the amazing Mr. That was sweet. Thank you. Oh, hey now. Yeah, nice. To the people. I appreciate it.
以及我们对你们和我们的朋友们有多么感激。所以基于这一点，我们今晚的嘉宾是我们所有人心爱的人，我们非常爱他。他简直太搞笑了。他是我们的好朋友。我们简直爱死他了。而且这已经，这是我们第一次，我们都知道嘉宾是谁，因为我们正处于巡演的尾声，我们邀请了我们的好朋友，我们的老铁，搞笑、善良、慷慨、了不起的先生……太暖心了。谢谢。哦，嘿。好嘞。为了大家。我很感激。
Hi, guys. You know, this guy knows how to do it. We got to get some pointers. I feel like that. I mean, that was a really nice intro. I don't think I don't appreciate it. I do appreciate it. But it did feel a little bit like mean, that was a really nice intro.
嗨，伙计们。你知道，这家伙真有一套。我们得向他请教几招。我觉得那个。我的意思是，那真是一个非常好的开场白。我不认为我不感激。我很感激。但确实感觉有点像，我的意思是，那真是一个非常好的开场白。
I don't think I don't appreciate it. I do appreciate it, but it did feel a little bit like, when somebody's inviting their cousin to your house, you're like, oh, he's such a great guy. You're not on so much. Don't be an asshole too. What the truth is is that, is that we mean it. Yeah, thank you.
我不认为我不感激。我很感激，但确实感觉有点像，当某人邀请他们的表亲去你家时，你会觉得，哦，他真是个好人。你别上台太久。也别太混蛋了。但事实是，事实是，我们是认真的。是的，谢谢。
We love you, and you're just a... Well, I love you guys, too. And I have to say, this is very exciting for me, because I've never seen Jason up this late. And by the way, if it's so important during the podcast, he just gets up and leaves, don't be surprised.
我们爱你，你只是一个……好吧，我也爱你们。而且我必须说，这对我来说非常兴奋，因为我从来没有见过杰森这么晚还没睡。顺便说一句，如果在播客期间有什么重要的事情，他直接起身就走，大家也别吃惊。
Yeah, that's every single time. Stay on one. There's no bones about it, too, right? He'll just get up and leave, and he and Amanda will often come to dinner or whatever we all know in separate cars. Yeah. So that he's got an escape pie.
对，每一次都这样。保持单一。这也没什么好隐瞒的，对吧？他会直接起身离开，而且他和阿曼达经常会开着各自的车来参加晚餐或者别的什么聚会。对。这样他就有了一条退路。
Last night, he lies. He's also a liar. Yeah, sure. He lied to me last night. By the way, it's funny that this is the big surprise. I saw you guys last night. I'm going to see you again tomorrow. I know.
昨晚，他在撒谎。他也是个骗子。是的，当然。他昨晚对我撒谎。顺便说一句，真可笑，这居然是个大惊喜。我昨晚才刚见过你们。我明天还要见你们。我知道。
Yeah, I know. I know. Another. I know, yeah, yeah. Really. Another day. Bridge. Grish merch, by the way. Oh, so great. This stuff, right? What, which mall kiosk did you get this made of? And I have to say, I made fun of the hats,
是的，我知道。我知道。另一个。我知道，是的，是的。真的。又一天。桥。顺便说一句，布里奇的周边商品。哦，太棒了。这些东西，对吧？你在哪个商场报摊买的这个？我不得不说，我嘲笑过那些帽子，
but I didn't know Zazzle was making motel key chains. I don't, listen. The key chains, by the way. Guess who's the idea of the key chains? Oh, shit.chains. I don't listen. The Keychains, by the way, guess who's the idea? The Keychains. Oh, shit, that was a... Yeah. What you were. Wasn't real.
但我不知道Zazzle现在还生产汽车旅馆钥匙链。我不知道，听着。顺便说一句，钥匙链。猜猜谁想出来的钥匙链？哦，该死，钥匙链。我不知道，听着。顺便说一句，钥匙链，猜猜是谁的主意？钥匙链。哦，操，那是个……是的。你当时。不是真的。
It was the real. Hang on a second. I may have said, now it's coming back to you. I may have said, key fob. That's like a mochelle. Oh, even better. What key fob? I have a Toyota Highlander.
那是真的。等一下。我可能说过，现在我想起来了。我可能说过，车钥匙扣。那就像一个莫谢尔。哦，更好。什么车钥匙扣？我有一辆丰田汉兰达。
I need a 2018 key fob. Who will he bob to some of these gym? That's, that's, I need a 2018 key fob. I told you Bob's is a new gym. That's that's I'm gonna destroy my marriage and cheat on my wife, key fob. Like what is that? Wait, wait, what's happening? Jail put that site down.
我需要一个2018款的车钥匙扣。谁会把钥匙扣送给这些健身房？那是，那是，我需要一个2018款的车钥匙扣。我告诉过你鲍勃的健身房是个新健身房。那是，那是，我要毁了我的婚姻并背叛我妻子的车钥匙扣。那到底是什么？等等，等等，发生什么事了？杰尔，把那个网站关了。
Oh, there we go. There's a key fob for the audience. A key fob is decorative. So last night, Jason, I left before you got here. I pulled a bateman, so I missed you. I got to be, honestly, I was surprised that you guys weren't there, and I thought, wow, this is really shitty of Jimmy Mollie,
哦，我们走吧。这是给观众的车钥匙扣。车钥匙扣是装饰性的。所以昨晚，杰森，在你来之前我就走了。我学了贝特曼的做法，所以没碰上你。老实说，我很惊讶你们不在那儿，我还想，哇，吉米和莫莉太逊了，
not to be here tonight. Yeah, so he took off before even I did. I was tired. We came late. It was a dinner thing. So did you. But Jason, when you were, I was walking in, and then moments later you were leaving.
今晚居然不来。是的，所以他甚至比我还早溜了。我累了。我们去得很晚。是一场晚餐活动。你也是。但杰森，当你的时候，我正走进去，然后过了一会儿你就离开了。
And I heard you were there. You said, and correct me if I misunderstood this, because I was trying to figure this out with my wife. You said, I said, you're leaving, obviously, and you said, yeah, I said, is Amanda your wife going with you? And you said, yeah, we rode together, and then you left, and then about 45 minutes later, there was Amanda. And I said, Jason said about 45 minutes later, there was Amanda.
我听说你在那儿。你说过，如果我有什么误解请纠正我，因为我当时正在和妻子理清这件事。你说过，我说，你当然要走了，你说，对，我说，阿曼达，你太太跟你一起走吗，然后你说，对，我们坐一块儿来的，然后你走了，然后大概45分钟后，阿曼达出现了。我说，杰森说大概45分钟后，阿曼达出现了。
And I said, Jason said, she's like, no, we came in separate cars. I don't remember saying that, I'm not saying that I didn't. Well, what, I didn't know what stage of the gummy that you're getting. Is that what happened? It was deep into the gummies. No, I just, I don't know what I'm saying when I'm leaving because I'm just trying to get the hell out of there.
然后我说，杰森说，她却说，不，我们是坐各自的车来的。我不记得我说过这话了，我不是说我没说。好吧，什么，我不知道你吃的那块软糖到哪个阶段了。是这么回事吗？那是吃了很强效的软糖。不，我只是，我不知道我离开的时候在说什么，因为我只是想赶紧离开那儿。
Yeah. And not be like the dick that's saying goodbye and wrecking the thing. I learned that from you, though. By the way, what time did you get there last night? Late, I got to go. Sorry, guys, we'll be right with you. Yeah.
是的。而且不想表现得像个说声再见却把事情搞砸的混蛋。不过我是从你身上学到这一招的。顺便说一句，你昨晚几点到的？很晚，我得走了。抱歉，伙计们，我们马上回来。是的。
Jimmy, I got a poll. You have mugs, too. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah. By all the stuff you want. So Jimmy, you were one of... You were on our show quite early on. Not as early as you should have been. Which was a big bonus contention.
吉米，我得走了。你还有马克杯呢。对，对，对。是的。买所有你想要的东西。所以吉米，你是……你很早就上过我们的节目了。虽然没有你本该上的那么早。这是一个很大的争端。
But as we explained, when you were on the show... Yeah. ...the three of us, nobody knew who to add. And it became one of those like, well, when are we gonna... Well, who's gonna have Jimmy and her suit as quite late? Right. But you were on early and you were in early. It's called being taken for granted. Yes, yes.
但正如我们所解释的，当你上节目的时候……是的……我们三个，谁都不知道该加谁。然后这就变成了一种，嗯，我们什么时候才能……嗯，谁能让吉米上节目，这挺晚的。对。但你很早就上节目了，而且你很早就开始听了。这叫被视为理所当然。是的，是的。
Yes. We can always get Jimmy. Let's take a swing at something. Yeah. But you were an early listener and you were somebody you had a lot of notes. I did, yeah. I did.
是的。我们随时都能找吉米。我们来尝试点别的。是的。但你是一个很早的听众，而且你是一个有很多意见的人。我是，是的。我是。
I did. I still do. This interview, you're out here tonight. We are interviewing you, but we really want to know what you think about our podcast. Yeah, how we know. So it's kind of about us. Well, I will be happy to share my notes.
我是。我到现在还是。这次采访，你今晚来到了现场。我们在采访你，但我们真的很想知道你对我们的播客有什么看法。是的，我们是怎么知道的。所以这有点关乎我们。好吧，我很乐意分享我的意见。
And first of all, I love the podcast. I honestly, no kidding around. I love listening to it. It's great because I have to say, I don't think you need guests. I don't think that. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. You need me here. Thank you. Thank you.
首先，我喜欢这个播客。老实说，不开玩笑。我喜欢听。这太棒了，因为我得说，我觉得你们不需要嘉宾。我觉得不需要。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。你们需要我在这儿。谢谢。谢谢。
Right, everybody. Thank you. Thank you. Exactly. Good night, everybody. Not at all. I love hearing you guys bust each other's balls. I love hearing the stories. I love... Oh, I love when you guys pretend to use the products
对吧，各位。谢谢。谢谢。没错，大家晚安。完全没有。我喜欢听你们互相开玩笑。我喜欢听那些故事。我喜欢……哦，我喜欢你们假装使用产品
and the commercials. I love that. So... You know... Wait, that... Wait, are you guys... No, Will's designing his own couch at home. Yeah, of course, with all form. Don't be a dick. Did you know they make mattresses now?
和拍广告。我喜欢那个。所以……你知道……等等，那是……等等，你们是……不，威尔在家里设计他自己的沙发。对，当然，用的是Allform。别当混蛋。你知道他们现在还生产床垫吗？
Yeah. It's so crazy, right? There's a lot of stuff in there. I'm not sure if I can do it. Yeah, of course, with all form. Don't be a dick. Ha-ha-ha-ha. Did you know they make mattresses now? Yeah. It's so crazy, right? They're so comfortable. Wait, which one do I have? I've got the organic hemp stuff with hay or something in it.
是的。太疯狂了，对吧？里面有很多东西。我不确定我能不能行。对，当然，用的是Allform。别当混蛋。哈哈哈哈。你知道他们现在还生产床垫吗？是的。太疯狂了，对吧？它们太舒服了。等等，我买的是哪一个？我买的是有机大麻材质的，里面好像还有干草什么的。
You fight with your daughter over the fake chick and McNuggets? Yeah. Did I say that? Yeah, oh yeah. Listen, the checks are clearing you guys. Yeah. Do you? Jimmy, I know.
你还为假鸡肉麦乐鸡跟女儿吵架？对。我有说过吗？对，哦，对。听着，支票正在兑现呢，伙计们。对。你呢？吉米，我知道。
You know what, the truth, sorry, go ahead, John. Oh, yeah, no. I was going to ask a real question. Well, I just want to just, just before we finish the commercial thing, it should be noted that we actually do legit you, I'm not trying to buy back for the ad for the ad for the others. I'm really not, but we weirdly legitimately do use
你知道吗，说实话，抱歉，你继续，约翰。哦，是的，不。我本来要问一个真正的问题。好吧，我只是想，在我们结束广告环节之前，应该指出的是，我们实际上真的合法地在使用你，我不是想为广告再买回广告费什么的。我真的不是，但我们确实出奇地、名正言顺地在使用
the money for the ad. Three quarters of them, I think is fair. Yeah, we won't say which ones we do. Of course you do. That would be cool. Thank you. We'll design these shoes on allform.com. Enter Smart List 20 for a 20% discount.
广告费。其中四分之三，我觉得很公平。对，我们不会说我们用的是哪几个。你们当然会。那太酷了。谢谢。我们在allform.com上设计这些鞋子。输入Smart List 20可享受80%的折扣。
Hey, they like our ad reads. Let me go to the rest of the show, and this is not something we have planned, but I do have some thoughts on it. One of my favorite moments in the show is right at the beginning. One of you introduces his guest, And the guest is sometimes fantastic. And sometimes they're usually pretty good. They're at least usually pretty good. Sometimes that's so great.
嘿，他们喜欢我们的广告词。让我回到节目的其余部分，这不是我们计划好的，但我对此确实有一些想法。节目中我最喜欢的时刻之一就在刚开始的时候。你们中的一个人介绍了他的嘉宾，而嘉宾有时表现得非常棒。有时他们通常也相当不错。他们至少通常相当不错。有时那真是太棒了。
But there is a moment where the person who brought the guest is all on board. And then the other two are decided there's two things going through the other two's mind, which is number one, if the guest is interesting, oh, oh, oh, what were they in? What am I gonna say to this person? And then the other one is trying to mask your disappointment. So there's always like a moment of...
但有这样一个时刻，带来嘉宾的那个人全力支持。然后另外两个人决定了，另外两个人的脑海里在想两件事，第一件事是，如果嘉宾很有趣，哦，哦，哦，他们演过什么？我对这个人说什么好呢？然后另一件事是试图掩饰你的失望。所以总是会有这样一个时刻……
A lot of tension. And there's also, if you listen carefully, there's a Google search going on. Yeah, for sure. Yeah, for sure. I mean, sure. You know, what are you going to do? Well, you will have the formula of, what is it?
气氛很紧张。而且如果你仔细听，还会听到他们在用谷歌搜索。是的，肯定的。是的，肯定的。我是说，当然。你知道，你还能怎么办？好吧，你们有一个公式，是什么来着？
Formula 41, Formula 1. Just one. Just one. Just one. Yeah. And Daniel Riccardo, which is a great episode. Daniel Riccardo. Yeah.
公式41，公式1。就一个。就一个。就一个。是的。还有丹尼尔·里卡多，那是一期精彩的节目。丹尼尔·里卡多。是的。
This is like, yeah. And I, I, I, I was like, oh, oh my god. Daniel Riccardo. This is a main Ricardo. This is a name. Riccardo. Oh, he races cars. Oh, yeah, it was something like that. The word car was right in his name the whole time.
这就像是，是的。然后我，我，我，我当时就想，哦，天哪。丹尼尔·里卡多。这是个名叫里卡多的。里卡多。哦，他赛车。哦，是的，差不多就是这样。车这个字一直在他的名字里呢。
So I also believe that there's more that can be done. And I know you guys are all very busy, but I think I would love to see a segment at the end of the show where you just take You read emails from your listeners. Yes, we got man that we talked about that great done. Yeah done. We talked about that No, nice. This is early. Yeah, but have you met people? These are good people here. I mean look at this. These people go these people are good people here. I mean, look at this. These people. No, these people are good. Good save.
所以我还相信，还有更多的事情可以做。我知道你们都很忙，但我认为我很想在节目最后看到这样一个环节，就是你们只管读听众的来信。是的，我们有，我们讨论过那个，太棒了，搞定。是的，搞定。我们讨论过那个，不，不错。这还挺早。是的，但你见过大家吗？这里都是好人。我的意思是，看看这个。这些人去，这些人这里都是好人。我的意思是，看看这个。这些人。不，这些人很好。漂亮的救场。
Well, I think that was a good save. How would you see this? I remember you guys started this podcast. Yeah. You were talking about it. And the big thing was, most of the discussion was, Bateman complaining about having to pay an editor to do this. And he's like, you know, we're doing this on our own.
好吧，我觉得那是个漂亮的救场。你们是怎么看待这个的？我记得你们刚开始做这个播客的时候。是的。你们当时在谈论这个。而最大的一点是，大部分的讨论都是，贝特曼在抱怨不得不付钱给剪辑师来做这件事。然后他说，你知道，我们是自己单干的。
You know, we're funding this whole thing, and I'm thinking, what are they funding? Zoom is free. Yeah. Microphones are $400. And how much could you be paying the editor? I mean, would it be very? No, I will say you brought up a very good point.
你知道，我们自己出资搞这个，而我在想，他们出资搞什么了？Zoom是免费的。是的。麦克风才400美元。你到底能付给剪辑师多少钱？我的意思是，会很多吗？不，我要说你提出了一个很好的观点。
The fellas that make this thing fly, and you should thank right right now who are here tonight Rob Armjard Betty Barberco and Michael Grant Terry Can't see them they're can't see him. They're here, though. They're here somewhere. Without them, we'd have nothing. Yeah.
让这档节目顺利进行的小伙子们，你们现在就应该感谢他们，今晚他们也在现场，罗布·阿尔姆贾德、贝蒂·巴巴尔科和迈克尔·格兰特·特里。看不见他们，看不见他。不过他们在这儿。他们就在这儿的某个地方。没有他们，我们什么都不是。是的。
I like to. We're like, put the house on something else. Fuck you. Yes. And we will be right back. Smartlist is supported by rocket money. So Scottie and I, you know, we share credit cards. We share everything. So, and we can't, you know, we share credit cards, we share everything.
我喜欢。我们就像是，把房子压在别的东西上。去你的。是的。我们马上回来。Smartlist得到了Rocket Money的支持。所以斯科特和我，你知道，我们共用信用卡。我们共享一切。所以，而且我们不能，你知道，我们共用信用卡，我们共享一切。
So, and we can't, like, he'll get a subscription to this thing, I'll get a subscription to that thing. And we can't keep it straight, like, who gets what, and what's to it. We wish we could just figure it out so we could simplify our life. And so we're not overpaying on redundant subscriptions, right?
所以，而且我们不能，比如，他会订购这个东西，我会订购那个东西。我们根本搞不清谁订了什么，以及这些费用是干嘛用的。我们希望我们能弄清楚这一点，以便简化我们的生活。这样我们就不会为冗余的订阅支付过多费用了，对吧？
Don't we hate that? Rocket money is a personal finance app that finds and cancels your unwanted subscriptions, monitors your spending, and helps you lower your bills all in one place. Most people think they're spending 80 bucks on their subscriptions, when in reality the number is closer to $200. When you're signed up for so many things like streaming services you used to watch one show, or free trials for delivery you don't use, it's so easy to lose track of what you're paying for.
我们是不是很讨厌那样？Rocket Money是一款个人财务应用，它可以在一个地方帮你查找并取消不需要的订阅、监控你的开支并帮助你降低账单。大多数人以为他们在订阅上只花了80美元，而实际上这个数字接近200美元。当你注册了太多东西时，比如你看了一部剧就闲置的流媒体服务，或者你根本不用的外卖试用期，你很容易就会忘记你到底在为什么付钱。
With Rocket Money you can easily cancel the ones you don't want with just the press of a button. No more long hold times or annoying emails with customer service. Rocket Money does all the work for you. Rocket Money can even negotiate to lower your bills for you by up to 20%. All you have to do is take a picture of your bill and Rocket Money takes care of the rest. You want to know how Rocket Money saved me? Still married. Stop wasting money on things you don't use. Council your unwanted subscriptions and manage your money the easy way by going to rocketmoney.com slash smartless. That's rocketmoney.com slash smartless rocket money.com slash smartless. This episode of smartless is brought to you in part by Skinny Pop Popcorn.
有了Rocket Money，你只需按一下按钮，就可以轻松取消那些不想要的订阅。再也不用面对长期的等待或是给客服发令人心烦的电子邮件了。Rocket Money为你代劳所有工作。Rocket Money甚至可以帮你将账单降价高达20%。你所需要做的就是拍下账单的照片，剩下的交给Rocket Money处理。你想知道Rocket Money是怎么拯救我的吗？我还结着婚呢。别再把钱浪费在不用 A东西上了。取消你不需要的订阅，以简单的方式管理你的资金，只需访问 rocketmoney.com/smartless。也就是 rocketmoney.com/smartless rocketmoney.com/smartless。本期 smartless 部分内容由 Skinny Pop 爆米花赞助。
Now I'm a big fan of the Skinny Pop. I eat it a lot. This is not difficult for me to tell you about this deliciously simple combination of popcorn, oil, and salt every bite of their perfectly popped original popcorn leaves you wanting more. Skinny Pop is light. It's tasty, perfect for any occasion, whether you're on the go, staving off boredom or unwinding after a long day. In addition to the original popcorn, Skinny Pop offers a variety of delicious flavors
现在我是 Skinny Pop 的超级粉丝。我经常吃。向大家介绍这种由爆米花、油和盐组成的美味简单的组合对我来说并不难，他们完美爆开的原味爆米花的每一口都会让你回味无穷。Skinny Pop 很轻。它很美味，适合任何场合，无论你是在路上、消除无聊，还是在漫长的一天后放松身心。除了原味爆米花，Skinny Pop 还提供各种美味的口味，
ranging from white cheddar to sweet and salty kettle. Now I am a Skinny Pop fan and you've seen me just mainlining this stuff. So, I don't know if you like what you see when you look at me, Skinny Pop's your call. Shop Skinny Pop now on Amazon. Smart List is sponsored by ADT. ADT Self Setup features everything from motion sensors to Google Nest Cam's with no long-term contracts. Early install the ADT Self-Setup Security System at your convenience.
从白切达干酪到甜咸口味的铁锅爆米花。现在我是 Skinny Pop 的粉丝，你已经看到我一直在大口吃这个东西了。所以，我不知道当你看着我时是否喜欢你所看到的，Skinny Pop 是你的首选。立即在亚马逊上购买 Skinny Pop。Smart List 由 ADT 赞助。ADT 自助安装功能应有尽有，从运动传感器到 Google Nest 摄像机，且无长期合同。在您方便的时候轻松安装 ADT 自助安装安全系统。
No heavy duty tools are needed, and if you need help, ADT can provide virtual assistance along the way. ADT Self-Setup grows, moves, and adapts as your needs change. You can add more products at any time, and your system easily moves wherever life takes you. It also features Nest cams that can tell the difference between a person, an animal, a vehicle, or with a Nest doorbell, even a package, all of which I have no idea what is what. I can't tell the difference between any of those things.
不需要重型工具，如果您需要帮助，ADT 可以在整个过程中提供虚拟支持。ADT 自助安装可随着您的需求变化而增长、移动和适应。您可以随时添加更多产品，并且您的系统可以随您生活带您去任何地方轻松移动。它还具有 Nest 摄像机，可以区分人、动物、车辆，或者配合 Nest 门铃，甚至可以区分包裹，所有这些我都不知道哪个是哪个。我分不清这些东西中的任何一个。
Plus, when I think the doorbell rings, I think it's Scotty, but no, it's a vehicle. And then I think it's a package, but no, it's Ricky. Plus, when every second counts, you can trust ADT's 24-7 professional monitoring. You can view video of an alarm event and verify or cancel an alarm with just a tap. When the most trusted name in home security adds the intelligence of Google,
另外，当我觉得门铃响了，我以为是斯科特，但并没有，是一辆车。然后我以为是个包裹，但并没有，是里基。另外，当每一秒都很重要时，您可以信赖 ADT 的 24/7 专业监控。只需轻轻一按，您就可以查看警报事件的视频并验证或取消警报。当家庭安全中最值得信赖的名字加入谷歌的智能技术时，
you've got a home with no worries. Go to ADT.com today or call 1-800-ADT-AS-AP. Google Nest Cam, Nest Doorbell, and Nest Aware are trademarks of Google LLC. All right, back to the show. But what about a podcast that you're on? Are you sick of talking to people? No, I don't need a podcast.
你就会拥有一个无忧无虑的家。今天就访问 ADT.com 或致电 1-800-ADT-AS-AP。Google Nest Cam、Nest Doorbell 和 Nest Aware 是 Google LLC 的商标。好了，回到节目中。但是关于你正在做的播客呢？你厌倦了和人说话吗？不，我不需要播客。
But this is enough. Why don't you like a show where you of talking to people. No, I don't need a podcast, but... You're this is enough. Why don't you like a show where you can talk to people and interview them and stuff? What do you mean? It would be fun. It would be nice to... You know what I really like to do is to plug people's projects. That's mine. Now, limit fashion.
但这就够了。你为什么不喜欢一个能和人说话、采访他们之类的节目？你什么意思？那会很有趣。那会很好……我真正喜欢做的是帮别人的项目打广告。那是我的。现在，限制时尚。
Imagine when you were a kid. When you were a kid, you were like, God, I just wish I could get to play. I wish. You know what? I wish I could tell. I know there's no such thing as a Netflix yet, but if there is one, one day, would you, would you, would you guest host this? Oh, this is the best.
想象一下当你还是个孩子的时候。当你还是个孩子的时候，你会想，天哪，我真希望自己能去演戏。我希望。你知道吗？我希望我能告诉。我知道现在还没有 Netflix 这样的东西，但如果有的话，总有一天，你会，你会，你会去客串主持这个吗？哦，这是最棒的。
This is my favorite part of the show. Yeah. The very, the longest questions in the world. Yeah. But not just the longest questions in the very, the longest questions in the world. But not just the longest questions in the world, but also their multiple choice. And when, and, and, sometimes they're answered within the question.
这是我节目中最喜欢的部分。是的。世界上最长的问题。是的。但不仅仅是最长的，世界上最长的问题。但不仅仅是世界上最长的问题，而且它们还是选择题。并且当，并且，并且，有时答案就在问题里面。
Yeah, absolutely. And the multiple choices are not ABC and D. They are just A and B. Yeah. But what if? Fuck all up. Could we, what about if I hosted your show for a week, well, you did this for a week,
是的，绝对的。而且选择题也不是 A、B、C 和 D。它们只有 A 和 B。是的。但是如果呢？去他的。如果我们，如果我替你主持一周的节目，你做了这个一周，
then he did your show for a week, you did this. Like, would you do this for three weeks, and we took turns doing this. 100% of four of four of four. I've been here. I've been here. You think of this already? Nothing would make me happier
然后他替你主持一周的节目，你做了这个。比如，你会做这个三周吗，我们轮流做这个。100% 四个中的四个。我一直在这儿。我一直在这儿。你已经想过这个了吗？没有什么比
than hosting your show for a week. To me, you have the best job in the world. I really want to be a week. We'll get you a week right now. If you'll commit to it, I think that's a lie. Why don't we do smart-less month? Yeah. Right? Oh, my God.
替你主持一周节目更让我开心的了。对我来说，你拥有世界上最好的工作。我真的很想干上一周。我们现在就给你安排一周。如果你肯答应，我觉得那是谎言。我们为什么不办个 smart-less 月呢？是的。对吧？哦，天哪。
I would... I just... You just look like you're always having so much fun. Yeah, really? You lie really. I just... Look at this face. Does this look like I'm having fun? What is so comfortable?
我……我只是……你看起来总是玩得很开心。是的，真的吗？你真会撒谎。我只是……看看这张脸。这看起来像我很开心吗？什么东西这么舒服？
Is he not like so comfortable up there and it's so nice to like sit there in bed late at night, you just kind of rock us to sleep and we're out. And it... It's a. And it's a compliment. It's a compliment. I know it's a compliment. Yeah. And I would take it as a, I would feel very touched if I didn't know for a fact that you are sound asleep at 9.45 and we're out of 9.
他在上面是不是超级舒服，坐在那里在深夜里，你只是把我们摇晃入睡，我们就睡着了。而且它……这是一个。这是一个赞美。这是一个赞美。我知道这是一个赞美。是的。如果我不是百分之百确定你在9点45分就已经睡得像死猪一样，而我们在9点离开的话，我会觉得很受触动。
I got one of those TV's. You're right, he is a liar. Yeah, he's a liar. And yeah, we shouldn't know this from when you were a child actor. We really should have known it. Now, you've been doing your show for so long, and obviously- He told him about Bateman or me.
我有一台那样的电视。你说的对，他确实是个骗子。是的，他是个骗子。而且是的，从你当童星的时候我们就该知道这一点的。我们真的早就该知道了。现在，你的节目已经做了很久了，显然……他跟贝特曼或我说的。
No, you. And I've heard rumors that you're going to be done in a year. I've heard other rumors that you're going to do for seven more years. Like, what are you feeling? It looks so interesting to me right here, right now. You know, it is funny how interested people in, and on, like, when I'm gonna leave already. It's a three of us, or a three of us.
不，是你。我听到有传言说你一年后就要不干了。我还听到其他传言说你要再干七年。你现在是什么感觉？此时此刻，这对我来说看起来太有趣了。你知道，人们对我要离开的时间如此感兴趣，这确实挺搞笑的。是我们三个，还是我们三个中的一个？
No, because we hope you never leave. Yeah, that's what people say, but I think it's like, like, if we were out just a party right now, you guys kept asking me when I was gonna leave. Right, yeah. Yeah. It would be weird.
不，因为我们希望你永远别离开。是的，大家都是这么说的，但我觉得这就好像，如果我们现在只是在参加一个派对，你们俩一直追问我什么时候要离开。对，没错。是的。那会很奇怪。
Yeah. And I feel like that all the time. No, no, no. Is this something you want to do forever? What forever? Your show, would you do it for another, for the same amount of time you've been doing it? I want to die on stage. On stage. You want to die on stage.
是的。我一直都有这种感觉。不，不，不。这是你想永远做下去的事吗？什么叫永远？你的节目，你会再做一段时间吗，做和你已经做的时间一样长的时间？我想死在舞台上。在舞台上。你想死在舞台上。
On stage. You want to die on life, too? We're not happy to best. I mean, the ratings would be tremendous. The show itself is pre-taped, right? So what does ABC do if I die during the show? Do they err? Do they run that night show?
在舞台上。你也想死在生活中吗？我们可不高兴到这地步。我是说，收视率会极高。节目本身是预录的，对吧？所以如果我在节目中途死掉，ABC 会怎么做？他们会播吗？他们会播那一晚的节目吗？
Of course. Sure. And I see when they're going to fall. We run that night show? Of course. Sure. And I see one there. We want to see that. Yeah, they, he's the hell out of it. Wait, wait, how are you dying? Um, massive heart attack. Sure.
当然。肯定的。我看看他们什么时候会倒下。我们播那一晚的节目吗？当然。肯定的。我看看他们什么时候。我们想看那个。是的，他们，他会把那期节目榨干的。等等，等等，你是怎么死的？嗯，大面积心脏病发作。当然。
Yeah. This is just just explodes at the desk. Yeah. Right, yeah. I think that, if you can do it during sweeps, it'd be fantastic. Oh, that would be great. Yeah, at the end of sweeps, yeah, for sure. Yeah. What do they do? I mean, I probably, like, said this be great. Yeah, at the end of sweeps, yeah, for sure. Yeah. What do they do?
是的。这就在桌子旁直接爆炸。是的。对，没错。我想，如果你能在收视率调查期间死掉，那就太棒了。哦，那太棒了。是的，在收视率调查期结束时，是的，肯定的。是的。他们会怎么做？我是说，我可能会，像写遗嘱一样把这个安排好，在遗嘱里我说明我的愿望。
I mean, I probably like said this up like a will, where I tell them what my wishes are. Right. As if I were to die on the show. I once had an overdose of Advil on the show, where my head, I know it sounds ridiculous, but it's possible. What does that look like?
就好像我要死在节目中一样。我曾经在节目中过量服用阿司匹林，当时我的头，我知道听起来很荒谬，但这是可能的。那是什么样子的？
It looks like a pumpkin head. It looks like your head expands. Why are you taking it? Because it's delicious. If you have an handle, you're like a M&M. They are. There's a sweetness to them. Yes.
看起来像个南瓜头。看起来你的头膨胀了。你为什么要吃它？因为这东西很好吃。如果你有一把阿司匹林，你就像在吃M&M豆。它们确实是。它们带有一种甜味。是的。
And they have a magic power that makes you forget how many you've already taken. Yes. Did you really have a bad reaction to it? I had a very bad reaction, and the show was live at the time, and so I started losing my voice. I might be having it now. I started losing my voice. And then my head started to swell up.
而且它们有一种神奇的力量，让你忘记自己已经吃了多少粒。是的。你真的对它有严重的过敏反应吗？我确实有很严重的过敏反应，当时节目正在直播，所以我的声音开始嘶哑。我现在可能也有这情况。我的声音开始嘶哑了。然后我的头开始肿大。
And by the end of the show, my head was really big. Come on. And I was introducing Rick Springfield. This was some time ago. And I've been on a long time now that I think of it. Tracey doesn't even need to fill in on that, right? Yeah, she's got it. Exactly.
到节目结束时，我的头真的变得很大。拜托。而且我当时正在介绍里克·斯普林菲尔德。那是很久以前的事了。现在想来，我已经在这个行业干了很久了。特雷西甚至不需要顶替那个，对吧？对，她搞得定。没错。
I did it, and then I went directly to Cinder's sign, I took the hospital to the ER. Yeah. And they were like, what did you do on us? Yeah. You started showing there. By the way, I have seen Sean at the ER. Have you really?
我做到了，然后我直接去了辛德的招牌那里，把车开到了急诊室。对啊。他们就问，你在我们这儿干嘛呢？对啊。你当时就在那儿露面了。顺便说一句，我在急诊室见过肖恩。你真的见过？
Yes! Yes, this is... No, you didn't know that. No! Yeah. I took a friend of mine... I took a friend of mine too. Exactly.
对！对，这是……不，你当时不知道。没有！对啊。我带我一个朋友……我也带了我一个朋友。没错。
Sometimes we get... We have a little double day, we go to the other friends. The cafeteria is delicious. But yeah, I was like sitting in a corner with my friend who was sick and you were standing up there and I was like, Jimmy, and you're like, Sean, or like, what's going on? And you're like, oh, I gotta go. I'm getting called in for your warm-up guy.
有时我们会……我们会有个双倍日，我们会去看别的伙伴。那里的餐厅可好吃了。但对啊，我当时跟我生病的朋友坐在一个角落里，你站在那边，然后我就喊，吉米，然后你说，肖恩，或者说，怎么回事？你说，哦，我得走了。我得去当你的暖场人了。
Yeah, my warm-up guy was having a panic attack and thought he was having a heart attack. So I had to take him in the bathroom. So you took Advil. And you had a friend there who was a famous person we shouldn't mention who it was. And they were like, you will anyway. Yeah.
对，我的暖场人当时正在恐慌发作，还以为自己心脏病发作了。所以我得把他带到洗手间去。所以你吃了阿司匹林。你在那儿有个名人朋友，我们不该提是谁。他们当时就说，你们反正还是会说出来的。对啊。
No, that's not true. They paid a lot of good money, Sean. Yeah. And they were like, you will anyway. Yeah. They paid a lot of good money, Sean. They still had this person was staying with me. And I took her to the ER because she was having a diverticulitis. Yeah, right. Right. I had a chat with the nurse, and I got you guys in.
不，才不是那样。他们花了很多好钱，肖恩。对啊。他们当时就说，你们反正还是会说出来的。对啊。他们花了很多好钱，肖恩。这个人当时还住在我家里。我带她去了急诊室，因为她得了憩室炎。没错，对。没错。我和护士聊了聊，然后我把你们带进去了。
Yes, you did. You know the thing, great thing is, the nurse cut, let you cut ahead of some people who were very, we're bleeding. And I just, you know what I mean? You know what I mean, a big fan. I looked at the room, I sized it up, I saw these bleeding guys, I was like, what are they gonna really contribute to society?
对，你确实这么干了。你知道最棒的是什么吗，护士破例让你插队走在了某些人前面，那些人当时伤得很重，我们在流血。我当时就，你知道我的意思吧？你知道我的意思，我是头号粉丝。我环顾了一下房间，估摸了一下情况，看到那些流血的家伙，我心想，他们对社会到底能有什么贡献？
It's Thursday night at one o'clock in the morning. I mean, they're bleeding. They were probably up to no good. Let's get this one-of-a-way. Yeah, yeah. Sean, how well do you know your way around? Oh, like the back of my hand. You do. Absolutely.
那是星期四晚上点钟。我是说，他们在流血。他们可能也没干什么好事。赶紧把这家伙打发走吧。对，对。肖恩，你对那儿的路有多熟？哦，了如指掌。非常熟。绝对的。
Yeah, because I get, here we go. I get a fib, right? So, you know what an atrial fibrillation is, right? Where your heart goes like this. Puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh-puh- your heart goes like this. Puh, puh, puh, puh. Yeah, it's actually. I don't know where we're going. It goes like this. And so I'm like normed from cheers. I just go in there like, hey, Sean, come on right in.
对，因为我，事情是这样的。我得了房颤，对吧？所以，你知道什么是房颤吧？就是你的心跳变成这样。扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-扑-你的心跳会变成这样。扑，扑，扑，扑。对，实际上。我不知道我们要去哪儿。它就是这样跳的。所以我就像《干杯》里的诺姆一样。我直接走进去说，嘿，肖恩，快请进。
And they put propa fall in, which is fantastic. And then they, Chacong, they knock my hearted back. And I go home. And it happens all the time. They do that. They do that. Yeah, one time it happened in New York. And they put me out. And I don't think they gave me enough.
然后他们给用了异丙酚，这药太棒了。接着他们，咔嚓一下，把我的心律给电击恢复了。然后我就回家了。这种情况经常发生。他们会这么做。他们会这么做。对，有一次在纽约也发生过。他们把我麻醉了。而且我觉得他们给的剂量不够。
And I'm not kidding. They went to Cacó and I woke up and I go, this is amazing. Yeah, I thought it was the most incredible feeling in that moment. Sean, do you have a nickname? No, what would my nickname be? Well, because I feel like I just came up
我没开玩笑。他们刚弄完我就醒了，然后我说，这太神奇了。对，我当时觉得那是这辈子最不可思议的感觉。肖恩，你有什么绰号吗？没有，我能有什么绰号？好吧，因为我觉得我刚刚想出了
with a great nickname for Sean. Is it paddles? It's paddles. Yeah. It's paddles. It's paddles. Come on. Do they say clear?
一个给肖恩的绝佳绰号。是叫电击板吗？就是电击板。对。就是电击板。是电击板。拜托。他们会喊“让开”吗？
Like, did you get it? I don't know. I'm out. But I do have a set of paddles at home. No, no. But I did say, I maybe said this on the package. I don't know, but I, you know. So I, yeah, so I, but the last time I went,
比如，你懂吗？我不知道。我不在行。但我家里确实有一套电击板。不，不。不过我确实说过，我可能在别的节目上说过这个。我不知道，但我，你知道的。所以我，对，所以，但我最后一次去的时候，
this is fascinating. Forgive me if I already told you this. I went in there and this is unbelievable. Never happened to me before. I'm there and my heart is pounding. And I go, I'm getting ready to go under. And the doctor says, okay, it's going into your veins. And I was like, oh my God, and I start shaking, which is a whole
这太迷人了。如果我之前已经讲过这个，请原谅我。我走进去了，这简直难以置信。以前从来没发生过在我身上。我躺在那儿，心脏狂跳。然后我说，我准备要失去意识了。医生说，好了，药剂进血管了。我当时就想，哦我的天哪，我开始浑身发抖，这整个
this story because I have a side effect. So I'm going like this. Like a beef paddles shakes or something. And so he's like, just try to relax. I was like, okay, and then the nurse goes, did you feel it? And I go, what? She goes, the procedure. I'm like, what?
故事是因为我有个副作用。所以我一直在抖。就像牛排电击板在抖一样什么的。所以他说，尽量放松点。我说，好吧，然后护士就问，你感觉到了吗？我说，什么？她说，手术。我说，什么？
She goes, yeah, we already did it. I'm like, what? She goes, yeah, we already did it. I'm like, what are you talking about? I like, I time traveled. It was like 20 minutes. It was, I've never experienced that. That sounds fantastic. That's battles for you. Wow.
她说，对啊，我们已经做完了。我说，什么？她说，对啊，我们已经做完了。我说，你在说什么呢？我感觉，我穿越时空了。就好像过了分钟似得。那种体验，我从来没经历过。听起来太棒了。这就是你的电击板外号的由来。哇。
That's fantastic. Oh, again, battles. That's classic battles. Yeah. I was trying to work on a joke like the first time baby got laid that she was, you know, like, paddles. That's classic paddles. Yeah. I was trying to work on a joke, like, the first time Baman got laid that she was either like, what had already happened?
太棒了。哦，又是电击板。这太经典了，电击板。对。这太经典了，电击板。对啊。我当时正想编个笑话，就像巴曼第一次破处时，她当时，你知道的，就像，电击板。这太经典了，电击板。对啊。我当时正想编个笑话，就像巴曼第一次破处时，她要么是觉得，怎么事情已经发生了？
You know what I mean? But I'm not doing that. Spending it right was not the venue tonight. Baman getting laid. I just want to say this. Jason Bateman might be the most interesting person I know. Yeah. I'm not sure.
你懂我的意思吧？但我没讲那个。今晚在这儿说这个可不是时候。巴曼破处。我只想说这个。杰森·贝特曼可能是我认识的最有趣的人。对。我不确定。
No. It's first of all, I agree. Yeah. I'm not sure. No. It's first of all, I think my wife would disagree with that. You hear little bits and pieces of the tales of the old days, which I was not around to witness, but it's like, you know, it's like you did play Teen Wolf, and it's like there was a... Two. Two.
不。首先，我同意。对。我不确定。不。首先，我觉得我太太绝不会同意这一点。你会听到一些当年那些疯狂岁月的吉光片羽，当时我不在场见证，但感觉就像是，你知道的，你确实演过《狼人少年2》。两个。第二部。
Also, also. Also. It's a big wolf. Yeah, it was T-Double-O. It wasn't T-W-O. Also, also. Also. It's a big wolf, I'm like, yeah, it's T-double-o. Wasn't T-W-O. It was also. In a way, you are team wolf because on, you know, you appear to be normal, and then there's this other guy who's this raging maniac, right?
而且，而且。而且。这是一只大狼。对，那是T-Double-O。不是T-W-O。而且，而且。而且。这是一只大狼，我就想，对，是T-double-o。不是T-W-O。而且也是。从某种意义上说，你就是狼人少年，因为你看上去很正常，然后还有另一个家伙，是个狂暴的狂热分子，对吧？
Right? Right? Yes, right. You never met the maniac. I didn't meet the maniac, but I didn't know the maniac. The maniac may have been doing something illegal backstage on... Well, you did meet the maniac. Yeah, I met the maniac. Yeah.
对吧？对吧？是的，没错。你从没见过那个狂热分子。我没见过那个狂热分子，但我认识那个狂热分子。那个狂热分子可能在后台做过什么违法的事情……好吧，你确实见过那个狂热分子。对，我见过那个狂热分子。对。
I just didn't know why the maniac was the maniac. You understand what I'm saying? I think so. We got paddles, and maybe Coke Wolf will be the character. We'll be the character from now on. But that aside, I mean, that's a whole thing just right there. But, oh, I remember that. I was there that night too. Andy Dick. Were you there that night?
我只是不知道为什么那个狂热分子会是那个狂热分子。你明白我在说什么吗？我想是的。我们有了电击板，也许可乐狼会成为这个角色。我们从今以后就用这个角色吧。但抛开这个不谈，我是说，光是这整件事就够了。但是，哦，我想起来了。那天晚上我也在那儿。安迪·迪克。你那天晚上也在那儿？
Yeah. Wait a second. Yeah, Coke. With you, dude. Wait, are you being serious? On my kids' line, yeah. We went there together. Sure we did. We must...
对。等一下。对，可乐。跟你一起，老兄。等等，你是认真的吗？以我孩子的名义，对。我们一起去的。当然去过。我们肯定……
We must dig up that clip. I know. Of your interview on the show that night and watch it together. Yeah. And perhaps do it on the podcast, so others can enjoy as well. It certifies we have the other time.
我们得把那段视频挖出来。我知道。就是你那天晚上在节目里接受采访的视频，然后一起看看。对。也许还可以在播客里播一下，好让别人也能欣赏。这证明了我们还有另一段过去。
I think we've already told this to all the podcasts. So, did we talk about the first time that I met Jason? And he said, oh, no, second, we were doing a rest of the other time I think we've already told this to other podcasts. Yeah, so, do we talk about the first time that I met Jason? And he said, oh, no, second, we were doing the rest of the development. He's like, man, I wish we just, this is when he was still part of, he was like, I wish we had just partied together once now, because you don't partied. I wish we just partied together.
我想我们已经把这个告诉过所有播客了。所以，我们有没有聊过我和杰森第一次见面？然后他说，哦，不对，第二次，我们在做其他事情的时候，我想我们已经跟其他播客聊过这个了。对，所以，我们聊过我第一次见杰森吗？然后他说，哦，不，等一下，我们当时在做发展的后续。他就像是，老兄，我真希望我们当时能一起狂欢一次，因为你没怎么狂欢过。我真希望我们能一起狂欢。
Because we'll have shut it down. I was still a year or two. I would have been awesome. We partied and I go, we did. And he's like, what are you talking about? Like, like five years ago, we went out, we had a big night, and you were with a friend of a friend, and he had done this show. We went a big night, and I remember he was so cool,
因为我们本可以把那场派对嗨翻天。我当时还是一两年。那肯定棒极了。我们去狂欢了，我说，我们确实一起狂欢过啊。然后他一脸茫然，你在说什么？就像，大约五年前，我们一起出去过，度过了一个疯狂的夜晚，你当时和某个朋友的朋友在一起，他当时做过这个节目。我们度过了一个疯狂的夜晚，我记得他当时太酷了，
because we went to this bar, we got all hammered, and then he like, not cool, but he got into his car, and he sped away, and I was like, this guy's a badass. You know what? You know, give a shit, he had a candle on his dashboard. Oh. So, I was like, this guy's a badass. You know what? You know, give a shit he had a candle on his dashboard. Oh. He had a lit candle on his fucking dash. Yeah, wait a minute.
因为我们去了这家酒吧，我们都喝得烂醉如泥，然后他就像是，不是酷，而是他上了车，然后一踩油门绝尘而去，我当时心想，这家伙太硬核了。你知道吗？你知道吗，他才不管三七二十一，他仪表盘上还点着一支蜡烛。哦。所以我当时想，这家伙太硬核了。你知道吗？你知道吗，他才不管三七二十一，他仪表盘上点着蜡烛。哦。他妈的仪表盘上点着一根燃着的蜡烛。对，等一下。
What? Wait. I know. Why? Ask any questions. You want to go ahead and why? Yeah, why? Why did you light a candle on your dashboard?
什么？等等。我知道。为什么？问任何问题。你想继续解释一下为什么吗？对，为什么？你为什么要在仪表盘上点蜡烛？
Oh. Where your headlights out? Oh. I don't know. I don't know. There was, I was driving a vehicle that had a dashboard that had a little cutout on top of it that just screened for a rego candle on me. I was just incredible.
哦。你的车头灯坏了吗？哦。我不知道。我不知道。当时，我开着一辆车，它的仪表盘顶部有一个小凹槽，正好可以塞进一支瑞格蜡烛。这简直太不可思议了。
That was just my rowdy candle, a fucking idiot. And I would light that thing and it would be blazing on my dashboard while I'm driving when I shouldn't so that the cops can see this dick's got a candle. I got a pole, it so steep it. Every night. By the way, instead of mugs, instead of keychains,
那只是我的疯狂蜡烛，我这个大笨蛋。我会把那东西点燃，它就在我的仪表盘上熊熊燃烧，而我还在开车，根本不该这么做，好让警察能看到这个混蛋点着蜡烛。我有个杆子，它太陡了。每天晚上。顺便说一句，与其送马克杯，与其送钥匙链，
maybe dashboard candles. That's the smartness. There you go. That's great. So a lot of those. You're right. That's a great idea. So even the drugs aside, whenever I mention some weird random celebrity to Jason,
不如送仪表盘蜡烛。这才是聪明之举。给你。太棒了。有很多这种。你说的对。这真是个好主意。所以抛开毒品不谈，每当我向杰森提起某个奇怪的随机名人，
it's become like a game that I don't know that he knows I'm playing, it's like a Bateman roulette. He has a great story about everything. All the time and actually right before the show, we were upstairs and somebody mentioned that Jason right now, just because he's, look, he's so handsome, we love him. And with his haircut right now, he's about to get a cut that he looks like
这就成了一个游戏，我甚至不知道他知不知道我在玩，就像是贝特曼轮盘赌。他对每件事都有个精彩的故事。随时随地，事实上就在节目开始前，我们在楼上，有人提到杰森现在，仅仅因为他，听着，他太帅了，我们都爱他。他现在的发型，他快要剪成那种看起来像
Christie McNichol, so, right? We said, and so of course, the obvious question is, as we're all laughing is, oh, by the way, hey, Bayman, do you know Chrissy McNichol? That's a legitimate question. He did it, but he admitted that he had a huge crush on her. Yeah. And then he had a dream about it to get this.
克里斯蒂·麦尼科尔的样子，对吧？我们这么说了，所以理所当然，当我们都在大笑时，显而易见的问题就是，哦，顺便问一句，嘿，贝特曼，你认识克里斯蒂·麦尼科尔吗？这是个合情合理的问题。他确实认识，而且他承认自己曾疯狂迷恋过她。对。然后他为此做了一个梦，你听好了。
He had a dream about her. And then he went jogging with his dad that morning after his dream, and he let his dad go ahead because as he was jogging, he was weeping. He was like, six great. Yeah, because I had it bad. Cracked. Anyway, I don't know, man.
他做了一个关于她的梦。然后在那个梦醒后的早晨，他跟他爸爸一起去慢跑，他让他爸爸先跑，因为他在慢跑时居然在哭泣。他当时就像，六岁真棒。对，因为我陷得太深了。崩溃了。总之，我不知道，老兄。
So now I grill my hair out like her. So... You went jogging with your dad? Yeah. I was... Right, Sean. I love that you're takeaway instead of the crime. Yeah, I know.
所以我现在把头发留得跟她一样长。所以……你跟你爸一起慢跑？对。我当时……没错，肖恩。我真喜欢你的关注点居然不是那个罪行。对，我懂。
I don't know. I'm trying to imagine myself jogging with my dad and I'm not seeing anything. By the way, me too. Yeah. Yeah. Wait, you're dead. Yeah. You're dead, big goat jogging.
我不知道。我试着想象自己跟老爸一起慢跑的场景，完全画面感全无。顺便说一句，我也是。对。对。等等，你爸已经去世了。对。你爸，一只山羊在慢跑。
You just went in a straight line. Still jogging. Still running. Still running away. And I can't catch up to him. So anyway, so we got all these random people. So I wrote down some names, and I just figured I'd throw some by you. Oh, my God, he was great.
你只是在笔直地跑。还在跑。还在逃跑。而且我根本追不上他。所以总之，我们有这么多形形色色的人。所以我写下了一些名字，我想我随便挑几个抛给你。哦，天哪，他太棒了。
You did. No one else. Mr. T. I knew him pretty good. Wait a minute. Lay it down. I don't know good. Wait a minute. I don't know. I don't know that. You did?
你做了。没有别人。T先生。我和他挺熟的。等一下。放下来。我不知道有多熟。等一下。我不知道。我不知道那个。你做了吗？
He knew him pretty good. No one knows him pretty good. I mean, what's not great? Not great. Well, my first place, my head goes to child adult. Why hanging out? Ha ha ha. My, uh, my mom became friends with... Ha ha ha. Mrs. T.
他挺了解他的。没人真正了解他。我是说，有什么不好的？没什么不好的。好吧，我的第一反应，我的大脑转到了儿童成人频道。为什么聚在一起？哈哈哈哈。我，我的妈妈和……哈哈哈哈。T先生的太太交上了朋友。
She knew she was really good at... She was tight with Mrs. T. Sure, go ahead. My, uh, my mother became friends with some personal trainer she met on a plane. She was a flight attendant, and he was Mr. T's trainer, and then Mr. T and I met, and then we rekindled when he was guesting on different strokes,
她知道她真的很擅长……她跟T先生的太太关系很铁。行吧，你接着说。我，我母亲和她在飞机上认识的一个私人教练交上了朋友。她是个空乘，而他是T先生的训练师，然后我和T先生就认识了，后来当他在《不同 Strokes》客串时我们又重新联系上了，
which I was filming next door to. And that was sort of fantastic. So that qualifies. You know, I once, I won some Mr. T, I was getting on a plane in New York to come here years ago. And there was like a jam up at the front door. And it was because Mr. T and flavor flavor were talking in the aisle.
那个节目就在我隔壁片场拍摄。那感觉简直太棒了。所以这符合条件。你知道吗，我有一次，我赢了某种T先生，好几年前我在纽约登机来这儿的时候。前面大门那里堵得水泄不通。因为T先生和弗拉沃·弗拉沃正在过道里聊天。
Really loudly. It was an incredible. That's true? Yeah. It was an incredible moment. He probably wanted to know what time it was. Yeah. LAUGHTER
声音超级大。那真是一个令人难以置信的。真的吗？对。那是一个令人难以置信的时刻。他大概是想知道几点了吧。对。笑声
Well, he pitted, yeah, he pitted the fool. Yeah, it was time to let's go ahead. All right, Bill Cosby. Oh. Be careful. Pass. No. I knew him only from when he was starting the Cosby show.
好吧，他确实，对，他把那个傻瓜给教训了。对，是时候了，我们继续吧。好吧，比尔·科 Cosby。哦。小心点。跳过。不。我只知道他从开始做《考斯比秀》的时候。
We were in New York doing all the upfront sales for stuff. I was on a show, it was on NBC, Cosby show is NBC. We were at the same table together and we talked, and we had a good time. Well, these are boring stories. Yeah, I don't have any dirty stuff. I didn't see their good stories. I said, he knows these people.
我们在纽约做所有的预先销售宣传。我当时在一个节目里，是在NBC播出的，《考斯比秀》也是NBC的。我们坐在同一张桌子旁聊天，我们度过了一段美好的时光。好吧，这些故事真无聊。对，我没有什么劲爆的料。我没说这些是好故事。我说过，他认识这些人。
Right, okay. Wait, so did you know them for a long time or? No, no. No, no. Okay. LAUGHTER One conversation, one table, a professional event. Okay.
好吧，好吧。等等，所以你认识他们很久了还是？不，不。不，不。好吧。笑声 一段对话，一张桌子，一场职业活动。好吧。
Next question. What about OJ? LAUGHTER Simpson, specifically. No, but we were at, I was at that Buffalo Bill's game that where he was on the sideline doing the reporting with the wooders wearing the shoes that they zoomed in on. And I was there because I was buddies with Jim Kelly at the time, and he was playing quarterback for the-
下一个问题。奥杰怎么样？笑声 辛普森，具体来说。没有，但我们当时在，我在那场布法罗比尔队的比赛现场，他在场边跟沃德斯一起做报道，脚上穿着特写镜头特意拍出来的鞋子。我在那儿是因为我当时跟吉姆·凯利是好朋友，而他当时是担任-
You were buddies with Jim Kelly? This is better, Buffalo Bill. Yeah, that- there's a good story there, but we don't have time. Ronald Reagan, you ever meet Ronald Reagan? I did not. Oh, okay, I was gonna make a while. I know. All right, Janet Jackson.
你跟吉姆·凯利是好朋友？这更厉害了，布法罗比尔。对，那——那里有个好故事，但我们没时间讲了。罗纳德·里根，你见过罗纳德·里根吗？我没有。哦，好吧，我还以为会有一段。我知道。好吧，珍妮·杰克逊。
Oh, yeah. I went to school with Janet Jackson. I used to- I used to. I went to school with Janet Jackson. I see. I see. We went to, we went to, we went to, where on the universe a lot. Close. I went to this, this, this poor excuse for a school called Valley Professional School, where, where kids who are trying to make it in business and show business go because it's only from 8 to 12, so you can go do auditions after 12. And it was like in a mini mall, deep in the North Valley, and she went to school there.
哦，对。我和珍妮·杰克逊一起上过学。我以前——我以前。我和珍妮·杰克逊一起上过学。原来如此。原来如此。我们去过，我们去过，我们去过，去了宇宙很多地方。差不多。我去了这所，这所，这所教学质量烂透了的学校，叫山谷专业学校，那些想在商业和演艺界闯出一片天地的孩子们都会去那儿，因为学校只有点到点上课，所以点之后你就能去参加试镜了。它就像是在一个迷你的购物中心里，位于北山谷的深处，她就在那儿上学。
I was some ice skaters went there. And that was just before the following year I went to a school called Heartlight, where... The old diamond school. Turn on your heartlight. Yeah. And this school, this had another new channel,
我记得有些花样滑冰运动员也在那儿上学。就在那之后第二年，我去了一所叫“心光”的学校，那儿……那所老钻石学校。点亮你的心光。对。这所学校，这有另一个新频道，
it's Jackson, but it's a good story. This school was very progressive, such that there were city days and country days. In the country days, you went to this dude's house in Calabasis. LAUGHTER I had the greatest parents in country days, you went to this dude's house in Calabasis. I had the greatest parents in the world, you guys. So you go to this dude's house, Monday Wednesday, Friday out in Calabasis and you do some scores.
是杰克逊的，但这是个好故事。这所学校非常前卫，甚至分城市日和乡村日。在乡村日，你会去这家伙在卡拉巴萨斯的家里。笑声 我爸妈简直是世界上最棒的……在乡村日，你会去这家伙在卡拉巴萨斯的家里。我爸妈简直是世界上最棒的父母，伙计们。所以你会去这家伙的家里，周一、周三、周五去卡拉巴萨斯外面上几门课。
You're like six kids in the whole school. And on city days, you get onto this bus, a full school bus, that the back half was converted into school desks. And the front half are regular seats, because you would go and you'd visit all the cultural sites in Los Angeles. But because we're in Calabas and the traffic is so bad, you can do schoolwork in the back of the bus on the way to these fucking things.
整个学校总共就六个孩子。而在城市日，你会上一辆巴士，一辆全尺寸的学校巴士，它的后半部分改装成了学校课桌。前半部分是普通的座位，因为你们会去参观洛杉矶所有的文化古迹。但因为我们在卡拉巴萨斯，交通太糟糕了，所以在去这些鬼地方的路上，你可以在巴士后部写作业。
And I think we paid, my parents paid, they didn't I'd pay for this shitty experimental school that wasn't accredited. So I let this one, so stupid. Listen to the schools I go to. So did you and Janet hang out like were your friends or were pretty friendly? That's nice. She's great. Like if you were to call her now, she would answer. We had our funny stories about Valley professional.
而且我想我们付了钱，我父母付了钱，不是我付的钱，为了这所毫无认证的烂七八糟的实验学校。所以我去上了这一所，太蠢了。听听我上过的都是些什么学校。所以你和珍妮经常一起玩吗，你们是朋友还是挺友好的？那挺好的。她人很好。如果你现在打电话给她，她会接的。我们有很多关于山谷专业学校的趣事。
Wow. When was the last time you spoke to Janet Jackson? It was sixth grade Sean and I did a I did an episode of Will and Grace was Sean and I played one of her back her background dancers No, but Sean and I Sean and I had a dance off. Yeah, High that go. Let's go. No, god, no. All right. All right. Let's go. I don't remember what Sean had.
哇。你上一次和珍妮·杰克逊说话是什么时候？那是六年级的时候，肖恩，我做过……我客串过一集《威尔和格蕾丝》，肖恩也在，我在里面扮演她的一个伴舞。没有，但肖恩和我……肖恩和我进行了一场舞蹈对决。对。进展如何？来吧。不，老天，不。好吧。好吧。来吧。我不记得肖恩当时是什么样了。
I just don't have some money. 5, 6, 7, 8. Boom. Boom. Go. There you go. There you go. But you know what?
我只是没有那么多钱。5，6，7，8。咚。咚。上。给你。给你。但你知道吗？
That was right after Nipplegate, right? And so that was nice of her to come on because she was, you know, it wasn't the best time for her. We'll be right back. SmartLess is supported by Audible. Audible lets you enjoy all your audio entertainment in one app. You'll always find the best of what you love or something new to discover.
那是“乳头门”事件之后不久，对吧？所以她能来上节目真的人很好，因为她当时，你知道的，那对她来说不是最好的时期。我们马上回来。SmartLess得到Audible的大力支持。Audible让你在一个应用中畅享所有音频娱乐。你总能找到你最爱的最佳内容，或者发现全新的惊喜。
Audible offers an incredible selection of audiobooks across every genre. You'll find guided wellness programs, theatrical performances, comedy, and exclusive Audible originals from top celebrities, renowned experts, and exciting new voices in audio. As an Audible member, you can choose one title a month to keep from the entire catalog,
Audible提供涵盖各个流派的不可思议的有声书精选。你会找到引导式健康计划、戏剧表演、喜剧，以及来自顶级名人、知名专家和音频界令人兴奋的新声音的独家Audible原创作品。作为Audible会员，你每个月可以从整个目录中挑选一本标题永久保留，
including the latest bestsellers and new releases. The audible app makes it easy to listen anytime, anywhere, while traveling, working out, walking, doing chores, you decide. The one I've listened to recently is Dean Coots, the house at the end of the world. It's really cool. I don't want to spoil the end of it,
包括最新的畅销书和新发布的作品。Audible应用让你随时随地轻松收听，无论是在旅行、健身、散步、做家务，全由你决定。我最近听的一本是迪恩·库恩茨的《世界尽头的房子》。真的很酷。我不想剧透结局，
but it's just like the one line that they have on the site. It says, soon no one on Earth will have a place to hide. And it's so good. It's all about like the end of the world stuff. And it's really, really exciting. New members can try Audible free for 30 days. Visit audible.com slash smart list or text smart list to 500 500. That's audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500 to try audible free for 30 days audible.com slash smartless. Hey smartless listener we get support from Viator. Experiences are what people love the most about travel am I right? They create long lasting moments that make memories and connections,
但就像他们在网站上写的那句话一样。上面写着：“很快，地球上将没有人有藏身之处。”这书太棒了。讲的都是世界末日之类的事情。真的非常非常精彩。新会员可以免费试用Audible天。访问audible.com/smartlist或者发送短信smartlist到获取。这就是audible.com/smartlist或者发送短信smartlist到来免费试用Audible天，audible.com/smartlist。嘿，SmartLess的听众朋友们，我们得到了Viator的支持。体验是人们在旅行中最热爱的事情，我说的对吗？它们创造了持久的时刻，留下的回忆和联系，
which will last well beyond the trip. Vietr is the place to go to book memorable travel experiences. They offer everything from simple tours to extreme adventures and all the niche interesting stuff in between. I've got a trip coming up with the family. We're gonna go to some place that's very historically significant. And I want to make sure that we go
这些将远远持续到旅行结束之后。Viator是预订难忘旅行体验的首选之地。他们提供从简单的观光旅游到极限冒险以及介于两者之间的所有小众有趣的内容。我最近有个家庭旅行。我们要去一个极具历史意义的地方。我想确保我们能去
and we see all the places that we're supposed to see and not just sit around and do nothing. This sounds like it could be right up my alley. All right, I'm excited. And listen, when you book a travel experience with Viator, there's always flexibility and support with free cancellation payment options and 24 or seven service. Plus, Viator has over 300,000 bookable experiences to choose from in over 190 countries.
参观所有应该去的地方，而不是只坐在那儿无所事事。这听起来完全符合我的胃口。好的，我很激动。听着，当你通过Viator预订旅行体验时，总是能享受到免费取消、灵活付款选项以及小时全天候服务的灵活性与支持。此外，Viator在多个国家/地区拥有超过万种可预订体验供你选择。
So there's something for everyone. Guys, this sounds great for me. Okay. Download the Viator app now and use code V-I-A-T-O-R-1-0 for 10% off your first booking. One app, over 300,000 experiences you'll remember. Do more with Viator. It is every parent's nightmare when folding in South Jersey, the search is on for an 11-year-old Cape-Made County boy missing since yesterday afternoon, so far, searchers have found only his left sneaker near his home.
所以总有一款适合大家。伙计们，这听起来对太棒了。好的。立即下载Viator应用，并使用优惠码V-I-A-T-O-R-1-0首次预订可享折优惠。一个应用，超过万个让你铭记的难忘体验。用Viator探索更多。这是每个父母的噩梦。在新泽西州南部福尔丁镇，搜寻工作正在展开，寻找一名自昨天下午起失踪的岁开普梅县男孩，到目前为止，搜寻人员只在他的家附近找到了他的左脚运动鞋。
It's hard to imagine losing a loved one, a wife, a husband, a child. For many, it's their biggest fear. Amarissa Jones, host of The Vanished, a podcast that tells the stories of often overlooked and unsolved missing persons cases. Every week, I dive into a new case, sharing the details of their mysterious disappearance, including interviews with family, friends, law enforcement, and even suspects in an effort to reveal the truth. And I'm proud to say that this podcast has aided in a number of arrests. It's important to me to remember the human behind the headline and help family members find their vanished loved one, or at least a sense of peace.
很难想象失去挚爱——妻子、丈夫、孩子——会是怎样。对许多人来说，这是他们最大的恐惧。玛丽莎·琼斯，播客《消失的人》的主持人，该播客讲述了那些经常被忽视且未破的失踪人口案件的故事。每周，我都深入剖析一个新案件，分享他们神秘失踪的细节，包括对家人、朋友、执法人员甚至嫌疑人的采访，努力揭露真相。我很自豪地告诉大家，这个播客已经协助破获了好几起逮捕行动。对我来说，重要的是记住头条新闻背后的那个人，并帮助家属找到他们失踪的亲人，或者至少获得一丝内心的平静。
Follow the vanished wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen ad-free on Amazon Music or the Wondery app. And now back to the show. Lucille Ball. Oh. Did you meet Lucie? I did not. Oh. I did.
在你的播客获取平台关注《消失的人》。你可以在亚马逊音乐或Wondery应用上收听无广告版。现在回到节目中。露西尔·鲍尔。哦。你见过露西吗？我没有。哦。我见过。
How old do you think I am? And then you read. I'm suggesting you were in school bus school together. Yeah. School bus school. Never met Lucy. Never met Lucy. All right, one more.
你觉得我多大？然后你读。我是在暗示你们是一起坐校车上学的。对。校车学校。从没见过露西。从没见过露西。好吧，还有一个。
Yeah. Hulk Hogan. Never. Never. Wow. Well, you've disappointed everyone. Sorry. Let me just toss in the same area, Lou Ferigno. Yes.
对。霍克·霍根。从来没有。从来没有。哇。好吧，你让所有人失望了。抱歉。让我顺便提个同一类型的，路·弗里格诺。对。
I have a story about Lou Ferigno and you're done, too. I played the Dodgers, the greatest baseball team in the history of sports. Wait a minute. Why would they be the greatest baseball team in the history of sports? Wouldn't they just be the greatest team in the history of the... I love how be, they'd just be the greatest team in the history of the... I've never had a great education gym. Oh, all right.
我有个关于路·弗里格诺的故事，你也讲讲吧。我为道奇队效力过，那是体育史上最伟大的棒球队。等一下。为什么他们会是体育史上最伟大的棒球队？难道他们不应该只是……历史上的最伟大球队吗？我太喜欢这种说法了，他们直接就成了历史上的最伟大球队……我从来没接受过好教育，吉姆。哦，好吧。
So, the Dodgers have this great celebrity baseball game every year, and I was lucky enough to play it at one year, and I somehow closed my eyes and put the bat on the ball and hit a gapper into the right center field. Lou Ferigno was playing right field, and I hit it right past the sprinting Lou Ferigno. It hit the wall, I hit it off Tony Dancer, by the way. Who's Tony?
所以，道奇队每年都有这场精彩的名人棒球赛，我很幸运有一年能去参加，我不知怎么闭着眼睛把球棒挥到球上，打出了一记穿透右中外野的安打。路·弗里格诺当时在防守右外野，球就从飞奔的路·弗里格诺身旁呼啸而过。球撞到墙上，顺便说一句，我是从托尼·丹扎那里打过去的。谁是托尼？
And Lou threw a seed back into the infield. There was a play at the plate. I got an inside the park home run. It's Dr. Stegon, let's get it going. Wow. Wow, but that's a legit Lou Ferigno story. Yeah. You're telling me you hit a line drive into right field
然后路把球像一颗子弹一样扔回了内野。本垒处发生了一次拼抢。我打出了一支场内全垒打。这是斯泰贡博士，我们开始吧。哇。哇，这倒是个正宗的路·弗里格诺的故事。对。你是说你打出了一记右外野的直线安打，
and managed to get all the way home and there were no errors committed? No, Lou had real skills. Now, Jonathan Silverman may have overthrown the home plate, but did we give you that hat and that motel key chain? I don't know if he gave it to me. It was sitting in a pile in the room in the prison cell you had me in.
然后成功跑回本垒，而且期间没有任何失误？不，路是有真本事的。现在，乔纳森·西尔弗曼可能把球传过了本垒，但是我们有给你那顶帽子和那个汽车旅馆钥匙链吗？我不知道他有没有给我。它就放在你把我关进去的那个监狱房间的杂物堆里。
Before I came out here, all everyone's so like, they can't see you. If they see you, they cannot see you. But meanwhile, back to the critiquing of the podcast. Okay, yeah. There's this big mystery of who the guest is gonna be in. You know, it's like, oh, there's so much mystery.
在我来这儿之前，所有人都一副，他们看不到你。如果他们看到了，他们绝对看不到你。但与此同时，让我们回到对这个播客的批判上来。好吧，对。这里有个巨大的谜团，那就是嘉宾到底会是谁。你知道的，这就像是，哦，里面有这么多的悬念。
Meanwhile, when we're listening, the name's right there on the be. And you know, it's like, oh, there's so much mystery. Meanwhile, we're listening, the names right there on the phone. I know, but it's only a mystery to you guys. Yeah, but that's not a mystery to us. That's kind of the fun. There's no mystery for us. Okay, oh, there's no mystery for them. For us, they're right, right, for the listener, right, right.
与此同时，当我们听的时候，名字明明就在那个上。你知道的，这就像是，哦，里面有这么多的悬念。与此同时，我们在听的时候，名字明明就在手机上。我知道，但这只对你们来说是个谜。对啊，但这对我们来说不是谜。这正是乐趣所在。对我们来说没有谜团。好吧，哦，对他们来说没有谜团。对我们来说，对听众来说，对，对。
Oh, yeah. For the people listening, there's nothing, but for you guys. Yeah. All right. There's a real rush. It's a really good point. OK, OK.
哦，是的。对听众来说，什么都不是秘密，但对你们来说。对啊。好吧。这真是一种刺激。这真是个好观点。好吧，好吧。
Except I'm torn. It's something that we, I've thought about that, but what do you want us to, we can just take the name off? Do you guys want us to take the name off? So you don't know? No, no, no, no. Fight it out. Fight it, guys.
不过我很纠结。这是我们，我考虑过这一点，但你们想让我们怎么办，我们可以把名字直接去掉吗？你们希望我们把名字去掉吗？这样你们就不知道了？不，不，不，不。争论一下。你们争论一下，伙计们。
No way. But it was, it was, it was an idea born of laziness. And Will and I were trying to remember whose idea it was. And you're saying it's yours. I can't remember who it was, but it was basically like, it was yours. Because we didn't want to do any prep. We're just like, just like, if I don't know who it is,
绝对不行。但这，这，这是一个出于懒惰诞生的想法。我和威尔当时在努力回想起这到底是谁的主意。而你说这是你的。我不记得是谁的主意了，但基本上就像是，这就是你的主意。因为我们不想做任何准备工作。我们就像是，如果我不知道他是谁，
then I'm going to ask really organic questions and post them thinking them through. Organic is a great word for it. What does it mean? I hear it all the time. No way, man. You didn't learn that at a snuff like that. You guys, you guys, we guys, this is a long light.
那我就要问一些非常有机自然的问题，然后边想边把它们抛出来。“有机”这个词用得真好。它是什么意思？我经常听到这个词。不可能，老兄。你可不是在那种乱七八糟的地方学到这个的。你们，你们，我们，老兄，这真是漫长的一天。
So. In World War II, you guys vacation a lot together. Or not a lot, but sometimes you guys vacation. We do. Do you have any kind of crazy Jason Bayman stories from vacation? Crazy, I mean, he only does... I'm gonna take a lot of fire. What about some funny stories about this guy?
所以。在二战期间，你们经常一起度假吗？或者说不是经常，但偶尔你们会一起度假。我们会的。你们有什么疯狂的杰森·贝特曼度假故事吗？疯狂的，我是说，他只会……我要挨不少骂。关于这家伙有什么好笑的故事吗？
You're a normal. I'm normal. He's pretty normal. Well, I mean, yeah, I mean, there are certain things that, I mean, it's interesting that you can be so tan in December. It's February. In England.
你是个正常人。我很正常。他挺正常的。好吧，我是说，对，我是说，有些事情，有趣的是你居然能在月份晒得这么黑。现在是月份。在英国。
In England under an umbrella. And then you say you're not using any kind of a tanning frame and to prove it, and this is the best thing, he makes us look at his feet. You know what I feel like right now? We're gonna find some weird sex thing up about you that you're really into, like, showing women your feet or something, like, and, like, we'll go, oh, yeah, you used to do that with the tanning thing,
在英国撑着伞的情况下。然后你说你没有用任何美黑喷雾，为了证明这一点，这是最棒的部分，他让我们看他的脚。你觉得我现在在想什么？我们马上就要挖出关于你的一些奇怪的性癖好，比如你特别喜欢这个，像向女人展示你的脚之类的，然后我们会说，哦，对，你以前跟那个美黑机做过这种事，
and then even when we did the smartless podcast with the Orpheum, he took off his shoe and he quickly showed his foot to everyone. He can't stop. I legitimately don't do anything weird. And I'm probably very sort of boringing that way. And yes, you show the feet because people who get spray tan, and I know some people who've had it done.
甚至当我们在奥菲姆剧院做Smartless播客时，他脱下鞋子，飞快地向每个人展示他的脚。他根本停不下来。我根本没有做过任何奇怪的事。而且我在这方面可能非常无趣。对，你展示脚是因为那些喷过美黑喷雾的人，我认识一些人做过这个。
Oh. I'm not going to say Justin Thoreau on the stage. Why would I...? Why would I say Justin Thoreau? That's wrong with me. Why would I say say a good thing? And then he's gonna get a hear about it and he's gonna be mad.
哦。我可不在台上提贾斯汀·塞洛克斯。我为什么要……我为什么要提贾斯汀·塞洛克斯？我这是怎么了。我为什么要提一个好事情？然后他就会听到这个，然后他会生气的。
So I'm just like, nah, I'm gonna say it, nah, another show. And you can see streaks on the stage. Yeah, like like, fall Giuliani. I'm gonna say, you'll never catch Justin throw on the rain. You'll never see a photo of him in the rain.
所以我当时就想，算了，我不提了，算了，换个节目。你能在台上看到条纹。对，就像鲁迪·朱利安尼一样。我要说的是，你永远不会在雨中抓到贾斯汀·塞洛克斯。你永远不会看到他在雨中的照片。
So, can't do it. But I've gotten to the point now where people say you're tan and I just say thank you. But I have like a real farmer's tan now. It's like a go. Oh yeah, you're a real farmer. I know. Like a gentleman farmer.
所以，做不到。但我现在已经习惯了，别人说你晒黑了，我只会说谢谢。不过我现在确实有了真正的农夫晒痕。就像一个。哦对，你是个真正的农夫。我知道。就像个绅士农夫。
I was thinking, what was I thinking about? You said one of your stories. That's what the Rick Springfield. Yeah. Did I tell you guys, did I tell the story on the show about, maybe think of Bruce Springsteen? Did I tell you about meeting Bruce Springsteen? No, everybody confused.
我在想，我刚才在想什么？你刚才讲了你的其中一个故事。就是关于瑞克·斯普林菲尔德的那个。对。我有没有跟你们讲过，我在节目里讲过那个故事吗，让我想想布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀？我讲过遇见布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀的事吗？没有，大家都搞混了。
Yeah, he even made a song about it. Think so, so one, this is years ago, I was in New York at Barney's on like a Wednesday, this whole clothing store on the Upper East Side of New York, at like 11 o'clock on a Wednesday, there was nobody up there. And I see Bruce Springseeing in there. Oh yeah.
对，他甚至为此写了一首歌。我觉得是的，所以，这个是几年前，我在纽约巴尼百货，大概是周三的时候，整个服装店都在纽约上东区，周三点左右，上面根本没人。然后我看到布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀也在那儿。哦，对。
Close shopping. And he's not obviously gonna try stuff on in the change room. He's just got like a pile on the counter. But he's just gonna take it all home with him. And then I guess send back whatever he does it like or it doesn't fit or whatever, right? So, legitimately, just the two of us.
买衣服。他显然不会在试衣间里试穿。他只是在柜台上堆了一堆衣服。但他打算把这些全带回家。然后我猜他会把那些不喜欢或者不合身之类的东西退回来，对吧？所以，说实话，当时就我们俩。
So he puts it on there, and then there's a guy working at the counter and sees and Bruce Springstein says, hey, can I just, I just want to put this on my account. That's a great Bruce Springstein. Thanks, man. Thank you. If I close my eyes, it's like I'm at the store with you. He says, and the guy goes, and the guy goes, no problem,
所以他把衣服放在那儿，然后有个店员看到这一幕，布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀说，嘿，能帮我把这些记在我的账户上吗？这真是一个绝妙的布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀。谢谢你，老兄。谢谢。如果我闭上眼睛，感觉就像我和你一起在店里一样。他说，然后那家伙说，然后那家伙说，没问题，
and he grabs the phone, and he goes, Oh, no. And he goes, I've got Rick Springfield here. No. True story. And I was just behind Springsteen as this happens, and he goes, we're just really feeling one of it. And to this credit, Springste brews brews brews steam.
然后他抓起电话，说道，哦，不。然后他说，我这儿有瑞克·斯普林菲尔德。不。真实的故事。当这发生时，我就在斯普林斯汀身后，他说道，我们其实真挺喜欢这首的。为了保持风度，斯普林……布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀……
And the guy's like, I mean brews brews steam and then hangs up. And then he was any kind of laughter. He turned to me and he just said, my kids would love it, it's fine. I was so fucking mortified, but yeah. Got all the clothes for free. It was a great moment.
那家伙说，我是说布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀，然后挂了电话。然后他没有任何笑意。他转过身看着我说，我的孩子们会喜欢它的，没关系。我当时尴尬得要命，不过对。拿到了所有的免费衣服。那真是一个美妙的时刻。
A great moment. That's pretty good. Yeah. And that's what clothes Barney's. Yeah. That's how to do it. That story, clothes pretty good. Yeah, and that's what close Barney's That story Close Barney. Yeah Now you're having us over tomorrow for Super Bowl. Very nice. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah You used to have a lot of super or football gatherings every weekend. Why did that stop did Molly get pissed off?
美妙的时刻。太棒了。对啊。这就是巴尼百货倒闭的原因。对啊。就是这么干的。那个故事，衣服真不错。对啊，这就是巴尼倒闭的原因。那个故事差点害惨巴尼。好吧，明天你要请我们去你家看超级碗。太棒了。对啊。对啊。对啊。你以前每个周末都会举办很多超级碗或橄榄球聚会。为什么不办了？是莫莉生气了吗？
No, no, no. Actually, my cousin, Sal, who is, who kind of organized the whole thing, took mercy on me because I was spending a whole day, Saturday, preparing for the Sunday. Me and you cook, because you cook. Yeah, because I cook everything. Everything.
不，不，不。事实上，我的表弟萨尔，也就是组织这一切的人，对我网开一面，因为我得花整整一天，也就是周六，来为周日做准备。我和你一起做饭，因为你做饭。对，因为我包办所有饭菜。所有的。
Every single thing. It's incredible, folks. And then Sunday would be me feeding those animals. Right. And this went on for like 11 years, and finally he's like, this is enough. This is too much for you. So you like cooking for that many people,
每一道菜。伙计们，这太不可思议了。然后周日就成了我喂养这群动物的日子。对。这种情况持续了大约年，最后他终于说，够了。这对你来说太累了。所以你喜欢为这么多人做饭，
don't you like maybe taking a break and having somebody cook for you? Like do you always do that? Oh yes, sometimes I go to restaurants even. Ha ha ha. What do we, what do we got tomorrow? What are you cooking up tomorrow? Tomorrow smoked pastrami, smoked chicken wings,
难道你不喜欢偶尔休息一下，让别人为你做饭吗？比如你总是自己做吗？哦，对，有时我甚至会去餐厅吃饭。哈哈哈哈。我们，我们明天吃什么？你明天准备做什么好吃的？明天有烟熏熏制五香牛肉，烟熏鸡翅，
my mother's making a vegan chili, the greatest mother. I'm making a big sandwich that has grilled zucchini and melted cheese and arugula on it, ribs. Can we do a part of that with those zucchini? Yeah, can you take the zucchini off? Just if I can make a request. Yeah.
我妈妈做的素辣椒，最棒的妈妈。我要做一个大三明治，里面有烤西葫芦、融化的奶酪和芝麻菜，还有排骨。我们能把西葫芦那部分去掉吗？对，能把西葫芦拿掉吗？如果我可以提个要求的话。对。
No problem. Just on a quarter of it? Yeah. Now, is half of that marinating right now? Like, did you prep today? I grilled the zucchini today, yeah. OK. We can toss it out.
没问题。只拿掉四分之一吗？对。现在，其中一半现在正在腌制吗？比如你今天是做准备工作了吗？我今天烤了西葫芦，对。好吧。我们可以把它扔掉。
I learned. Wait, but what? What makes it? I'd have never even heard of it. Look at the mat you are. Why are you so mad? Because I'm the loser of a zucchini. what, I'd have never even heard of him. Look at the mad you are. Why are you so mad? Because I'm the host of a zucchini sandwich. You know what, because he needs popcorn.
我学到了。等等，但是什么？是什么让它？我甚至都没听说过这东西。看看你生气的样子。你为什么这么生气？因为我是个西葫芦的输家。什么，我甚至都没听说过它。看看你生气的样子。你为什么这么生气？因为我是个西葫芦三明治的主办者。你知道吗，因为他需要爆米花。
He needs popcorn. What? He's hungry. Why, who's ever heard of a zucchini sandwich? That's terrible. But you know what, look, he gets, so he hasn't had anything to eat for like 45 minutes. Yeah.
他需要爆米花。什么？他饿了。为什么，谁听说过西葫芦三明治？太难吃了。但你知道吗，看，他，他已经分钟没吃东西了。对。
You know what I mean? You know what I mean? First of all, I want to get him some food. Great, because I made it for you, number one, because you eat like a princess. Yeah. And I'm gonna have, I'm gonna go outside my comfort shop. So I'm gonna get you some popcorn? No, I had a bunch of, I'm not gonna crap for a week, guys.
你知道我的意思吗？你知道我的意思吗？首先，我想给他弄点吃的。太好了，因为我就是为你做的，第一，因为你吃得像个小公主。对。我要吃，我要跳出我的舒适圈。所以我去给你拿点爆米花？不，我吃了一堆，我这周都别想拉屎了，伙计们。
We get some popcorn. We get some popcorn. We get some popcorn. Maybe some popcorn. Maybe some popcorn. Thanks, man. Oh, that some popcorn. Maybe some popcorn. Maybe some popcorn. Thanks, man. Oh, that's great. Thanks so much.
我们拿了些爆米花。我们拿了些爆米花。我们拿了些爆米花。也许来点爆米花。也许来点爆米花。谢谢，老兄。哦，那点爆米花。也许来点爆米花。也许来点爆米花。谢谢，老兄。哦，太棒了。非常感谢。
It was bringing it right over here. Thank you. This is a good sign of ours. Oh, that's great. Who's that? Wait, wait, wait, wait. Jennifer Aniston. What?
它正往这边拿呢。谢谢。这是我们的好标志。哦，太棒了。那是谁？等等，等等，等等，等等。詹妮弗·安妮斯顿。什么？
What? What? What? What? What? What? What? What?
什么？什么？什么？什么？什么？什么？什么？什么？
What? What? What? What? What? I'm going to go this way. I'm going to go this way. I'm going to go this way. I'm going to go this way. I'm going to go this way. I'm going to go this way. I'm going to go this way. I'm going to go this way. I'm going to go this way. I'm going to go this way.
什么？什么？什么？什么？什么？我要走这边。我要走这边。我要走这边。我要走这边。我要走这边。我要走这边。我要走这边。我要走这边。我要走这边。我要走这边。
I'm going to go this way. I'm going to go this way. I'm going to go this way. I'm going to go this way. I'm going to go this way. I'm him. Look at him. Look at him. Look at him. Look at him. Look at him. Look at him. Look at him. Look at him.
我要走这边。我要走这边。我要走这边。我要走这边。我要走这边。我是他。看他。看他。看他。看他。看他。看他。看他。看他。
Look at him. Look at him. Look at him. Look at him. Look at him. Look at him. Look at him. Look at him.
看他。看他。看他。看他。看他。看他。看他。看他。
Look at him. Look at him. Look at him. Look at him. Look at him. Look at him. Look at him. Look at him. Look at Okay, yeah, I don't need it. Jennifer Anderson!
看他。看他。看他。看他。看他。看他。看他。看他。看他。好吧，是的，我不需要它。詹妮弗·安德森！
Jennifer, I got to you! Oh my God! I thought I heard that laugh backstage. Jennifer, would you grab me a sparkling water please? Haha! By the way, it's so funny because it was very nice for you guys plotted when I came out, when these guys came out, it felt like real enthusiasm, it definitely made me feel good.
詹妮弗，我找到你了！我的天哪！我以为我在后台听到那个笑声了。詹妮弗，能帮我拿瓶气泡水吗，拜托？哈哈！顺便说一句，这太有趣了，因为你们刚才在我上台、这几个人上台时鼓掌，感觉真的很热情，这确实让我感觉很好。
And then Jennifer Aniston comes out and you're like, oh, we're a bunch of fucking slugs. Oh, man. Oh, man. That's like, ah! That's the best. The best. There you go, buddy. All right, so I'm gonna go outside my comfort zone tomorrow.
然后詹妮弗·安妮斯顿一出来，你就觉得，哦，我们真是一群他妈的废柴。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。这就好像，啊！太棒了。最棒的。给你，老弟。好吧，明天我要走出我的舒适区。
I'm gonna have ribs. Yeah? I'm gonna have what else is... You don't have any of these things. You're gonna sit there and pretend to be eating. No, no. So you can imagine. To be fair, what about last night?
我要吃肋排。是吗？我要吃还有什么……你根本没吃这些东西。你坐在那儿假装在吃。不，不。所以你可以想象。公平地说，昨天呢？
I mean, I was just a shit pig last night. I put everything in me last night. Yeah. I... Hi. If you're... If you're... There's almost always a video in this illegally,
我是说，我昨天就像个饭桶。我昨天往肚子里塞了所有东西。是啊。我……嗨。如果你……如果你……这里几乎总有一段非法的视频，
please put that... Just that clip on the internet. I put everything in me last night. Thank you. And then... And I get it back. And then follow it with, do I have 2B? Yeah. Hey, you want to know what?
请把那个……就把那个片段放到网上。我昨天往肚子里塞了所有东西。谢谢。然后……然后我把它吐出来了。然后接着问，我有2B吗？Yeah. 嘿，你想知道什么？
Yeah. This is true. We told some other people before. 2B, since December, this has gone up 40%. Yeah. It's true. It's true. But what's 40% on 2B?
是的。这是真的。我们之前跟其他人说过。2B，自12月以来，这个数字上升了40%。是的。这是真的。这是真的。但2B上的40%是多少？
It's like eight people. Who's But what's 40% on 2B? It's like 8 people. Who's going to win the game tomorrow, Jimmy? Well, I don't know. Wait, wait. Do you know who's playing them all? Of course, I know who's playing. Who? Well, the bangles and the ramps.
大约八个人。谁是但2B上的40%是多少？大约8个人。谁会赢得明年的比赛，吉米？嗯，我不知道。等等，等等。你知道谁在打吗？当然，我知道谁在打。谁？嗯，孟加拉虎队和公羊队。
All right, good. Or, as everyone says, all the time, the bangles and the ramps, as if Susanna Hoffs and the gang. Yeah, yeah, I'm gonna say. Are taking on Matt Stafford. I mean, it's ridiculous. Bangles and jaguires, those are the two things. I'm just make every hair on my body stand up
好吧，很好。或者，正如大家一直所说的那样，孟加拉虎队和公羊队，就好像苏珊娜·霍夫斯和她的乐队。是啊，是啊，我想说。正在对阵马修·斯塔福德。我的天，这太荒谬了。孟加拉虎和美洲虎，就是这两样东西。我身上的每一根汗毛都竖起来了
when I'm watching football. I wanna get back to Bateman's eating for one second. Yeah. Because we were on the ball. And that is the title of his new book, Jason Bateman eating for one second. Yeah. And that is the title of his new book, Jason Bateman, Eating for one second. We're on the road. The food shame was off the chart.
当我看着橄榄球的时候。我想回到贝特曼的吃东西这事上，就一秒钟。是的。因为我们在聊正事。这就是他新书的书名，杰森·贝特曼吃东西一秒钟。是的。这就是他新书的书名，杰森·贝特曼，吃东西一秒钟。我们在路上。食物羞耻感简直爆棚。
Oh, yeah. Consulate gauging, what are you having? What are you eating? I'm not going to have that now. It's waiting too late with the, it's waiting. Yeah. Right, John? Yeah, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then. Well, I get nightmares if I have it too late. And then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then, Well, I get nightmares if I have it too late.
哦，是的。控制饮食，你吃什么？你在吃什么？我现在不吃了。太晚了，等……等。是吧，约翰？是的，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后。嗯，如果吃得太晚我会做噩梦。然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，然后，你想吃太晚，你想吃太晚，你需要恶魔来。他就像那种人，嘿，我要点些甜点。我不吃那个甜点。三，二，一。你那有什么？是的。
You need too late, you need too late, you need the demons come. He was like, he's the king of like, Hey, I'm going to order some dessert. I'm not eating that dessert. Three, two, one. What do you got there? Yeah.
你来得太晚了，你来得太晚了，你需要恶魔来。他就像是，他就像是个国王，嘿，我要点些甜点。我不吃那个甜点。三，二，一。你那拿着什么呢？是的。
You started, I finished. I just used that term. He said, he was doing the ordering for the room service. We all started to see him room on tour every city. It was such a mistake. And every night, and so Jason's ordering dinner one night, and he's taking the order from all of us, and then he goes, he's got the person on the line.
你开始，我结束。我刚用了那个词。他说，他当时在为客房服务点菜。我们所有人都开始看他巡游每一个城市。这真是个错误。每天晚上，所以有一天晚上杰森在点晚餐，他在记录我们所有人的点单，然后他走过去，拿着电话线上的人。
And then he goes, and turns to shot and goes, what do you want, shit pig? The person, like, imagine is like, what the fuck is going on? So you're gonna be the woman. Good, and I'm like, I said, I have the spare ribs and he goes, yeah, the pig will have some spare ribs. It's all good fun.
然后他走过去，转向肖恩说，你想吃什么，饭桶？那个接电话的人，就想象一下，会觉得，这他妈的怎么回事？所以你要演那个女人。很好，我说，我要一份烤肋排，然后他说，对，这头猪要来点烤肋排。这都是闹着玩的。
It is all good fun. See you can resist the popcorn. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, it's so much. Skinny Pop, the best popcorn in the world. No, it's a camera. Where's the camera? Not a sponsor. Speaking of fun, Jimmy, it's been so fun having you.
这真的都只是闹着玩。看你能抗拒爆米花。不，不，不，不，不，不，不，太多了。Skinny Pop，世界上最棒的爆米花。不对，这是摄像机。摄像机在哪？不是赞助商。说到好玩，吉米，有你来真是太有趣了。
Thank you for coming. Jimmy, that's it. It's over. It's over. No, no, I'm fine. I like to watch the rest. I know. We love you. We thank you. You're the best. Wow. rest. I know. I know. We love you.
谢谢你能来。吉米，够了。结束了。结束了。不，不，我挺好的。我想看剩下的。我知道。我们爱你。我们谢谢你。你是最棒的。哇。剩下来的。我知道。我知道。我们爱你。
We thank you. You're the best. Wow. Thanks. I know. You know what? I appreciate it. I appreciate all of you for coming here tonight.
我们谢谢你。你是最棒的。哇。谢谢。我知道。你知道吗？我很感激。我很感激大家今晚能来到这里。
And I also want to make one more comment about the show. Yeah, go ahead. Go ahead. Thank you, Jen. You guys do the real lives. You can't do the rest without shoes? Go ahead, Jimmy. Yeah. No, I love the show.
我还要对这个节目做最后一个评论。好的，说吧。说吧。谢谢，詹。你们过着真实的生活。没有鞋子你们就没法继续了吗？说吧，吉米。是的。不，我喜欢这个节目。
I'm glad that I feel like it's so exciting to see all these people come to see you guys do this, which really came out of just the very private conversation between the three of you and then sometimes really good and sometimes not so good guests. And I'm so happy for you. And I hope you guys are appreciative of the magic that this is because it is a wonderful thing. These people are here.
我很高兴，看到这么多人来看你们做这个节目，我感到非常兴奋，这其实源于你们三个人之间的一次非常私密的对话，然后有时候嘉宾真的很棒，有时候又没那么好。我为你们感到高兴。我希望你们能欣赏这种魔法，因为它是一件美妙的事情。这些人都在这里。
And to hear the dismissive way you talk about them off the air is just... I just find it offensive. I know me too, and I tell them all the time. I find it very offensive. I'm with you. But these are the best. Yeah, these are the best. They're the best, yeah. Thank you, buddy. Thanks, guys.
听到你们在节目下台后用那种轻蔑的语气谈论他们，简直是……我只是觉得被冒犯了。我知道我也是，我一直在跟他们说。我觉得非常被冒犯。我和你同感。但这些都是最棒的。是的，这些都是最棒的。他们是最棒的，是的。谢谢你，老弟。谢谢你们，伙计们。
Thank you, Ravi. Thank you, everybody. Thank you, Ravi. Thank you, everybody. Thank you, everybody. Thank you, everybody. Thank you, everybody. Thank you, everybody. Thank you, everybody. Thank you, everybody.
谢谢你，拉维。谢谢大家。谢谢你，拉维。谢谢大家。谢谢大家。谢谢大家。谢谢大家。谢谢大家。谢谢大家。谢谢大家。
Thank you, everybody. Thank you, everybody. Thank you, everybody. You did good. Thank you, everybody. You did good. Thank you, everybody. You did good.
谢谢大家。谢谢大家。谢谢大家。你们做得很好。谢谢大家。你们做得很好。谢谢大家。你们做得很好。
Thank you, everybody. You did good. Thank you, everybody. You did good. Thank you, everybody. You did good. Thank you, everybody. You did good.
谢谢大家。你们做得很好。谢谢大家。你们做得很好。谢谢大家。你们做得很好。谢谢大家。你们做得很好。
Thank you, everybody. You did good. Thank you, everybody. You did good. Thank you, everybody. You did good. Thank you, everybody. It was so fun having somebody who's important to us out here up for the last night. You guys are here at the last show of the tour. Yes, thank you. Thank you for being here. I've said it to Jimmy's face on his show. I said all the time that he's one of the kindest. He really is everything you think he is.
谢谢大家。你们做得很好。谢谢大家。你们做得很好。谢谢大家。你们做得很好。谢谢大家。能在最后一天晚上有对我们如此重要的人来到这里真是太有趣了。你们来到巡演的最后一场秀了。是的，谢谢。谢谢你们的到来。我在吉米自己的节目上当面告诉过他。我一直都说他是最善良的人之一。他真的完全如你所想的那样。
He's one of the kindest, most generous people in the business. We all love him. It's something, you should know. He said, if any of our guests dropped out on this tour all over the country over this last week, week and half, he says, I will get on a plane and I will fly there and I will sit there.
他是这个行业里最善良、最慷慨的人之一。我们都爱他。有一件事，你们应该知道。他说，如果我们在过去一周、一周半里在全国各地的这次巡演中，有任何嘉宾临时缺席，他说，我会坐上飞机飞过去，坐在那里。
It's where they got true story. And yeah, he jokes around a lot, but he does really have these, he's just got such a squishy sort of center. And he's always the first, you know, he really does. He's like the guy who will just always offer to help or do what he's, it's amazing on top of being incredibly hilarious and just, and a gorgeous hard candy shell on the outside.
这就是他们真实的故事。是的，他经常开玩笑，但他确实有这样一面，他有着非常柔软的内心。他总是第一个，你知道的，他真的会这样。他就像那种总是主动提出帮忙或者做他该做的事的人，这太神奇了，更不用说他极其搞笑，而且外表有着华丽坚硬的糖衣。
Yeah, yeah. Back to food. So, yeah. You got to get that looked at. Um, um, but anyway, so thank you guys so much. I mean, it's just been incredible. I'm not know. I feel shocked Thinking right is it fucking smoke coming out of his ears try to work on you know what he's trying to do I just wish you know, I just wish we could have spent more time with Jen. You know, but it feels so nice to be here. Get out of here!
是啊，是啊。回到食物上。所以，是的。你得去看看那个了。嗯，嗯，不过无论如何，非常感谢你们。我是说，这简直太不可思议了。我不知道。我觉得很震惊，脑子里在想，是这家伙耳朵里冒烟了吗，试着搞清楚……你知道他在试图做什么？我只是希望，你知道，我只是希望我们能有更多时间和詹相处。你知道的，但在这里感觉太美妙了。滚开！
Come on! Come on, yeah! I wanna do this. Just say hi. Hi. Thank you for coming. Hi, everybody. Thank you for coming. And if you were here.
来吧！来吧，是的！我想这么做。打个招呼就好。嗨。谢谢你们的到来。大家好。谢谢你们的到来。如果你当时在这里。
OK, I think this has been really a lovely, lovely evening. And I wish I could just come up with something, something sort of something to say something like like something. Something. Oh, we like like goodbye. Bye. Bye. Thank you so much.
好吧，我觉得这真是一个可爱、美好的夜晚。我希望我能想出点什么，某种东西，某种可以说的话，就像某种……某种东西。哦，我们喜欢像再见。再见。再见。非常感谢。
Thank you, my lady. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you, thank you. Thank you. Cheers. Cheers. Cheers.
谢谢你，女士。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢，谢谢。谢谢。干杯。干杯。干杯。
Cheers. Cheers. Cheers. Cheers. Cheers. Cheers. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armjurff, Bennett Barbaco, and Michael Grandterry. Smart loss.
干杯。干杯。干杯。干杯。干杯。干杯。Smartless是由罗布·阿姆朱夫、贝内特·巴巴科和迈克尔·格兰特里100%有机手工打造的。Smartless。
In the first part of the 20th century, the Hilton family had a luck on the hotel industry by offering upscaled service at a modest price. The company was expanding fast and buying up iconic properties across the country, like the Plaza and the Waldorf Astoria, but their unchallenged rise wouldn't last. An ambitious Mormon named J.W. Marriott decides to pivot from restaurants to hospitality, and he's after Hilton's business, developing modern hotels across the world, but both the Hilton and Marriott families will have to contend with their share of drama in finding a successor, while also fighting to stay solvent in a high stakes business.
在20世纪的前半叶，希尔顿家族以适中的价格提供高端服务，垄断了酒店业。公司扩张迅速，在全国收购了标志性的物业，如广场酒店和华尔道夫酒店，但他们无可挑战的崛起不会持续太久。一个雄心勃勃的摩门教徒名叫J.W.万豪，决定从餐饮业转型为酒店业，他紧盯着希尔顿的生意，在全球开发现代酒店，但希尔顿和万豪家族都必须在寻找接班人的过程中应对各自的戏剧性事件，同时还要在风险极高的商业中努力保持偿付能力。
Hi, I'm David Brown, the host of Wondery Show Business Wars. We go deep into some of the biggest corporate rivalries of all time. In our latest season, Hilton and Merriott are in a race to expand globally and secure the loyalty of fickle customers. Make sure to follow business wars wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen ad-free on the Amazon Music or Wondery app. of thick old customers. Make sure to follow business wars wherever you get your podcasts.
嗨，我是大卫·布朗，Wondery节目《商战》的主持人。我们将深入探讨史上一些最大的企业竞争。在我们最新的季度中，希尔顿和万豪正在争夺全球扩张，并确保善变客户的忠诚度。请在您获取播客的任何地方关注《商战》。您可以在亚马逊音乐或Wondery应用上收听无广告版。善变客户的忠诚度。请在您获取播客的任何地方关注《商战》。
You can listen ad free on the Amazon Music or Wondery app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以在亚马逊音乐或Wondery应用上收听无广告版。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。